This is Jocko podcast number one 49 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
But Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Okay.
All my life,
I've waited for this.
Okay,
now I've joined you and your losses are a strength to me.
I ache.
And yet I know that Alec retched with pain on the dust road that went to
Corinth.
I breathed the dust and yet I know that grandpa brief the gas that made a hero
out of purging.
I flinch when bullets tear the air in angry rents.
And yet I know that father and three farmer boys at Pickett's charge felt a
cutting edge that dropped them dead.
How can I be bitter?
You are my strength.
You ghosts.
And I have learned those things,
those esoteric skills and knowledges that mark me as one of you
that loose bowels,
piles of shit.
Too much shit from overeating.
PLOP randomly around the outer dykes of a Ville mean trouble.
Yeah,
catching the aroma,
seeing the groupings,
watching flies,
dance laser Lee rejoicing in their latest fitted morsel that bends the low grass
and a muddy glob like a bomb of cow dung
trouble.
I can tell from the crack of a rifle shot the type of weapon fired and what
direction the bullet is traveling.
I can listen to a mortar pop and no,
it's size,
how far away it is.
Okay.
I know instinctively when I should prep a tree line with artillery before I move
into it.
I know which draws and fields should be crossed online which should be assaulted
and which are safe to cross in column.
I know where to place my men when we stopped and form a perimeter.
I can shoot a rifle and throw a grenade and direct air and artillery on to any
target under any circumstances.
I can dress any type of wound.
I have dressed all types of wounds,
watered protruding intestines with my canteen to keep them from cracking under
sun bake,
patched,
sucking chest with plastic tied off stumps with field expedient tourniquets
I can call and Med evac helicopters.
Talk them,
cajole them,
dare them into any zone.
Yeah,
I do these things,
experience these things repeatedly.
Daily.
They're terrors and miseries are so compelling and yet so regular that I have
ascended to a high emotion that is nonetheless a crusted numbness.
Okay?
I am an Automaton bent on survival agent and prisoner of my misery.
Okay.
How terribly exciting
and how to,
what purpose will these skills serve me when this madness ends?
What lies on the other side of all this?
Yeah,
it frightens me.
Okay.
I haven't thought about it.
I haven't prepared for it.
I am so good.
So ready for these things that were my birthright.
I do not enjoy them.
I know they've warped me,
but it will be so hard to deal with a life empty of them
and there are the daily sufferings you go,
so have known them,
but who else
I can sleep in the rain wrapped inside my poncho listening to the drops.
Beat on the rubber like small explosions.
Then fuel the water pour to reveal.
That's inside my Poncho soaking me as I lie in the mud.
I can live in the dirt,
sit and lie and sleep in the dirt.
It is my chair and my bed,
my floor,
and my walls.
This clay
and like all of you,
I've endured diarrhea as only an animal should endure it.
Squatting a yard off the trail and relieving myself.
Unceremoniously.
Naturally.
Animaly
deprivations of food festering,
open source worms eat aching crotch that nags for fulfillment.
Any emptying hole that will relieve it.
Yeah.
Who appreciates my sufferings?
Who Do I suffer for?
And that right there is an excerpt from a book.
Okay.
That is called fields of fire.
And it was written after the Vietnam War by a marine who served there.
Yeah.
In this book paints a picture of,
of combat and it,
and in fact it actually does more than that because a picture,
no picture supposed to paint a thousand words or say a thousand words,
but pictures don't always properly convey thoughts and emotions.
Yeah.
You need words to make that happen.
And this book really captures all of it.
Horror,
fear,
disgust,
love,
hate,
indifference.
The chaos of combat,
the sorrow of loss here.
Wisdom.
Okay.
And of course,
in all of that human nature
and
okay,
as I always say about this podcast,
while yes,
it is about ward,
it's about leadership.
And it's about atrocities.
And it's about struggle.
It is,
most importantly,
it's about human nature.
And on top of that,
the incredible power of the human will.
And this book fields of fire gives us a very close examination of human nature
in all of its glory
and of course in all of its horror as well.
And the book was written by a man by the name of James Webb,
who was a marine officer,
Vietnam recipient of the Navy Cross,
former secretary of the navy,
former senator from the great state of Virginia.
He's written a bunch of other books,
10 I believe.
Okay.
He's written and produced movies,
all kinds of stuff.
On top of that,
east has five children,
if I'm correct,
or one of those children.
Jim also served in the Marine Corps and it was actually whose time in Ramadi
overlapped with my time in Ramadi,
where he served as a,
as an oh three 11 rifleman as a member of the one six marines and also as a
radio men in Stapleton.
So
it's awesome to read these books and know their history and it's even more
awesome and an absolute honor to have with us here today,
the author of the book,
fields of fire
and also his son.
So sir,
thank you for coming,
Jim.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you.
I witness,
I was kind of wondering because you've,
you know,
James and Jim and I decided when I was trying to figure out what to call you
guys,
I,
I figured I'd call you young Jim,
Jim,
and I just keep calling you sir.
Just call me Jim.
I call him young easier.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I,
I can't thank you guys enough for coming on,
for coming all the way out here from the east coast and to come on this and um,
for me to revisit fuel to fire,
which is just a,
uh,
a book and what,
we'll get into that a little bit later.
It's an iconic book about not just the Vietnam War,
but really about Warren and the,
the way you've laid it out.
And again,
we'll get into that a little bit,
but I also wanted to talk to you and really get some of your backstory as well
and your upbringing.
You know,
we always try and start with the guests kind of talking about where they came
from and what their background was.
And you have a lot of that actually laid out in your memoir.
So I was going to ask if it's cool to call this a memoir,
but there it says it on the cover,
a memoir I heard my country calling and I guess what one little section of this
that that stuck out at me and I think you know,
obviously we'll let you expand on it,
but I'm going to the book.
So again,
this book is called,
I heard my country calling and here we go back to the book when it hurts,
just grit your teeth and take it.
Don't ever,
don't you ever back down?
Never start a fight.
But if somebody else does never run away,
if you run from a bully,
you will never stop running.
But if you fight,
he won't risk coming back at you again.
Stand up,
fight back,
mark him,
give him something to remember every morning when he looks in the mirror,
then even if you lose,
you win.
And by the way,
if you ever run from a fight,
I will personally beat your ass
and you go on.
My father was not exactly a mellow guy.
He did not spare the Rod,
but he taught me early that there is no substitute for moral courage,
whatever the cost and that the ultimate duty of every leader is to take care of
the people who rely on him when otherwise they would be forgotten or abandoned.
Courage in the face of those above you and loyalty to those below you where my
father's in alterable standards,
the only true way to measure the worth of another human being.
So there you go.
Those are some,
those are some standards your dad laid out for you.
He was a tough guy,
not a tough guy.
You know,
listening to you read the,
um,
the excerpt from fields of fire.
I was just thinking about how long it has been and the journey that I've had
since I wrote those words.
And learning.
I think we were talking about this last night,
learning how to write by writing this novel,
writing a novel.
It was an act of will for a lot of different reasons.
And
one of the things when,
when I think about growing up in our family,
uh,
was,
my dad was a leader,
uh,
more than anything.
He was a leader and you know,
bit different families have different conversations when you,
when you're sitting around the dinner table.
But his was always,
you know,
he would talk about different issues,
but it was always,
how do you lead?
How do you motivate people?
Uh,
one of his,
uh,
slogans was you can make people do something or you can make people want to do
something.
And so in a nutshell,
you know,
learning from him,
he was a career military person.
He enlisted in World War II,
became a bomber pilot,
uh,
be 17 to be 29 in Zen,
was in Berlin airlift.
And when I was very young and,
uh,
was transitioning into a jets for the Korean War and uh,
air pressure in the cockpit blew out the jet blue blue's your out.
He got grounded.
I'll never forget that day when he came home,
when he,
he couldn't fly anymore.
We're getting worried from to walk into the door and my mom says they took your
dad's when he's away,
don't ever mention it.
He walked in and he was still wearing his wings.
You know,
once you qualify them,
they don't take off.
And so first thing I said to him was,
Hey dad,
you,
they let you keep your wing.
So he said,
go upstairs.
But then he was a pioneer and the muscle programs still didn't have a college
degree.
Put the first atlason for the air force.
And one of the,
one of the great things to observe as a teenager was when they gave him the
command of a,
an atlas Thor scout junior and missile squadron that the success rate on the
atlas at this time out of Vanderburg,
we had opened up van and it was an 85,000 acre wilderness when I first went out
there in,
in eighth grade.
But the success rate and that squadron was 11% and he made it 100% 12 out of 12
successful launches.
And I'd go with them out to the,
the pads don't,
you know,
went out in 1617 and and watch how he dealt with his is people,
wait,
you just trumped,
cause I was talking about how I bring my,
I used to bring my son out to the training grounds and let them shoot machine
guns and stuff.
But your dad brought you out and let you shoot missiles.
Let me watch you just trumped me as the,
you know,
you could back then,
I could go sit a cinder block house like a thousand yards away from where one of
these outlets are going up.
But watching how he treated his people and on a,
you know,
he'd been deployed a lot when he went back into the million.
He got rift at the end of World War Two because he didn't have a college degree
when they brought him back in.
He was either deployed or stationed at basis that did not have military housing
for three and a half years.
And we were up in Saint Joe,
Missouri where I was born.
Uh,
my father's family had come in from the Appalachian Mountains and ended up in
Saint Joe.
My mother was from East Arkansas.
Uh,
very,
she had a very tough life.
Early life.
Three of her seven siblings had died with childhood disease.
The kinds of things you don't even see anymore,
like her,
her sister that was nearest to her died of typhoid fever.
When's the last time we'd seen in American with typhoid fever?
Um,
so we were up in Saint Joe,
Missouri.
My mother had four kids by the time she was 24 years old and my dad was gone and
she didn't know hardly anybody at Saint Joe Missouri.
We didn't have these family assistance programs like they do now.
And it's been one of the great privileges of my life to try to put those into,
into our military.
So my grandmother moved in,
she,
she was living on Arkansas,
I mean,
from Arkansas to California and came back and lived with us for several years
and there was an iron hand in a house.
But you know,
my dad would come back,
he'd leave Friday night and get off work at one point.
But Scott Air Force Base Illinois drive 380 miles one way every weekend.
No interstates drive all night.
Friday night show up.
We never knew what time Saturday morning,
but he'd be in there with,
with my mom's Saturday morning raise hell,
uh,
Friday afternoon,
getting,
getting the car and drive back.
Uh,
but his example taught me more about the axioms of leadership than anything I
learned anywhere else.
And being able to apply it in the Marine Corps,
which you know,
was one of the great prides of,
of my life,
uh,
was,
really an extension of what he'd put on the Table Day in a day out.
And you know,
Jim got the new son,
Jim got to know,
uh,
you know,
his grandfather and my dad very well.
We spent a lot of time fishing,
hunting.
We are an outdoor family.
Um,
and we've had a same kind of few thousand hours of discussions,
I think.
Yeah,
you can very easily say that the passage you read will qualify as the 11th
commandment in our household.
Growing up,
I always passed down to him and it passed down to me.
Very,
very,
very simple.
You never walk away from a fight.
Um,
I've never start a fight,
but,
uh,
never walk away from one,
ever quit.
And you'll be judged how you treat those around you.
And it's a,
it's a,
it's,
it's been,
uh,
one of those things I've kept with me my entire life and it's,
I was lucky to have that kind of formative influence at a very young age.
And,
uh,
I love the Marine Corps myself,
but everything I've learned about leadership is from him and being around his
platoon growing up.
And it's absolute blessing.
Yeah,
that's awesome.
I know and we talked about this a little bit last night cause I would have guys
that are concerned that hey,
I'm not around and I got two kids and I'm doing another deployment.
And,
and you know,
I always would tell guys,
look,
guys have been,
I don't know what you call it in,
you know,
Viking years or whatever,
but I don't know if they called it a deployment back then,
but guys have been going on deployment and leaving their families for thousands
and thousands of years.
And,
and that to me is an example that you might not be there to directly influence
your kid on a day to day basis.
But the,
when when,
uh,
the young man looks up or a kid looks up and sees,
hey,
this is what hard work is this,
what commitment is this is,
this is what sacrifices and they can emulate that.
You don't have to be there everyday to instruct them.
And every single little thing that they do.
And I mean,
clearly both of you are examples of that.
You can turn out just fine,
even if dad isn't around every night.
Oh,
you know,
when I was really,
uh,
when I was really young and he was deployed the Berlin airlift,
I used to go to a better reunite with a picture of him on the runway and the
flight line,
uh,
that air force public affairs had taken with him and his first sergeant or some
visiting general.
I still have that picture over my desk today.
Uh,
but that was,
you know,
that was good night dad.
You know,
and you look at that and you,
you gain an understanding of what it means to serve and what,
what your country,
uh,
is all about and,
you know,
serving your country,
those sorts of things.
The one thing I would say it was my dad really didn't want me to go in the
Marine Corps.
He,
uh,
from the job that we were just talking about,
you know,
when you had the,
uh,
the missile squadron,
he had gone to night school for 26 years.
He graduated from college in my senior in high school and you meet,
it was deep selected for colonel.
Um,
and then they send him to the Pentagon to do legislative affairs and it was the
Mcnamara era and he would just,
he would just go crazy about,
uh,
the whiz kids who were running the Vietnam War and we would have these long
discussions about,
you know,
you're,
you're just going to be meat.
You know what,
you're going to be meat.
You know,
the Marine Corps is a political football,
don't do it.
His,
his line was go in the navy,
stay on the ship,
eat ice cream.
And then when I went in the marine corps,
it was like,
oh man.
And then when my brother went into the marine corps,
my brother was a Huey pilot in the Marine Corps.
It was like,
my boys are marines.
Uh Hm.
I,
you know,
going back to your childhood a little bit,
you talk about how you moved around a ton.
I'm grown up.
I mean,
you sound like your dad was a little bit of a habitual house mover.
Even when you get somewhere he would move.
No,
you're talking about you.
When you were in England,
you live in 303 different houses and it seems like everywhere you went you would
move around a lot.
And one of the things you say about that in the book is a,
I'm going back to the book here.
I not only learned how to read a room,
but by necessity became an acute observer of subtle body language of each new
tribal circle.
In each place I learned valuable distinctions that helped me to develop skills
and insights that carried over into leadership challenges during,
during my later life.
In order to lead people,
you must first motivate them in order to motivate them.
You must understand them in order to understand them.
You must be able to grasp not simply their words,
but the emotion behind their words.
The same words and gestures can have vastly different intentions in Alabama and
southern California and Nebraska.
And sometimes even within the same town.
I learned to be a receiver of information as well as a careful broadcaster.
So
absolutely.
You know,
and first of all with,
with my dad moving.
Yeah.
We,
I think the longest we've ever lived in a house,
it was like 17 months while I was growing up,
you know,
part of it was the,
the Scotch Irish tradition of the,
uh,
the Ulster Scotts at settled Appalachian mountains and then spread further west
and,
uh,
you know,
they're there,
they like to say,
you know,
you,
you haven't,
you don't stop moving to,
you've lived in at least two or three houses or something over the mountain that
you haven't seen yet.
And uh,
yeah,
I'd eat that.
Literally,
we,
yeah,
we got,
you know,
the does post World War Two military,
uh,
was,
you know,
it would still solid sort of receipting itself in terms of having large standing
military and where the missions were going to be with the space program,
all this stuff,
missile program going on.
So yeah,
we by necessity moved a lot,
but then yeah,
we'd get in a house,
Amarillo,
Texas,
women,
Amarillo,
Texas,
one year it would have been three different houses.
You know,
I saw one down there.
So I'm done there on sunset.
I'm upset to the street,
we're going to move in that house.
And my brother and I,
we lived on the back porch,
you know,
that with the,
the windows rattling a,
you know,
et cetera.
But as we're testing to either become marines or start a moving company,
you are really,
so then there was an upside is the downside of that.
And that is,
you know,
academically like,
and went to I think nine different public schools in five years at one point
with three different schools in eighth grade.
No,
you know,
continuum in the academic curriculum.
Um,
when I started in the eighth grade that was in Santa Maria,
California,
when they first opened up,
Vandenberg,
uh,
they tested the whole class.
They took four of us.
They put us in different rooms.
I said is it was like the beginning of gt,
you know,
or whatever.
Uh,
you know,
you're going to,
you're going to be like an experiment.
You're going to grow it academically at your own rate.
By the time I got to one,
two,
three,
like the fifth school in,
in Nebraska,
I was on non college prep work release,
get this Guy Outta here.
You know what I ended up,
you know,
like they let us go an hour early and I went to work,
but I can always take a standardized test.
And that's really how I was able to get into the,
the,
uh,
scholarship program that later led me to go to the,
to the Naval Academy.
But the most important lesson from all of that was I was able to see such a
cross section of America,
uh,
first in the military.
You know,
the military was the first institution in the country that was racially
integrated.
And we had a totally different environment than if I had grown up in east
Arkansas or somewhere else,
but also so many different communities.
And you walk in and you're the new guy and you read the room and you figure out
where the problem is.
But you also,
as you know from,
from the,
from the quote that you read,
you learn that a big part of leadership is knowing what motivates people and
understanding that different things motivate different people,
not only culturally but individually.
And so sort of figuring out,
uh,
what,
you know,
what a person is thinking when they are saying certain things to what body
language means,
et Cetera.
And you translate that into the combat environment,
particularly in,
in Vietnam,
during the Vietnam War when I was there and we had an incredible cross section,
particularly of the,
the working side of American society.
Uh,
and,
and uh,
I,
by that time I'd been a boxer for eight years.
I had been around,
you know,
a lot of African Americans.
My hero when I was in high school was African American.
Incredible fighter wins the Olympics in 1964.
Um,
but uh,
the uh,
Hispanic communities,
California,
the farming communities,
the southern,
the southern mentality of which my culture deprived.
Um,
and so when you look at a problem,
we look at a potential problem.
You know,
I got cat and ones,
I got cat four's in terms of,
you know,
the,
the testing scores of people out there.
You learn how to,
how to listen and then how to make decisions and how to preclude a lot of
problems that were going on.
We had racial problems and in the military writ large during that period we are,
society had these problems.
I never had a racial problem in any,
you know,
documented.
Did you now one of the things that while you are jumping from school to school,
and that was prob problematical,
although you would learn in this stuff about human nature and the way people
are,
you know,
one part of the book here,
you say from,
from the time I was 10,
my dad had challenged me to read a book a week and if,
and if that did not remedy my restlessness to try and read two books a week,
read,
hears me,
and I had including poetry fiction history and anything I could get my hands on
that was about sports and the military.
Did you read that much as a young kid?
Constantly.
And I thought really saved me in terms of the,
you know,
the differing standards and whatever in the schools that I was going to.
And the other thing that,
uh,
my dad and I would do from the time I was very young,
it was,
had poetry contests,
you know,
he was a big,
big reader too.
And,
uh,
so,
you know,
all the way through his,
his lifetime,
we would do that when,
uh,
you know,
up until,
very soon before he passed away,
we would go every summer we'd get the,
the males in the family of the different generations,
get a fishing camp in Minnesota for two weeks and hang out,
build a fire,
goof around and catch fish,
clean fish,
talk,
talk.
And my dad and I would always,
we'd do Kipling or we'd do the British and Irish poets and you know,
one of us had give a line and another would give another line to see who really
remembered,
you know,
and I always knew when I was in high school when he,
when he was wanting to go,
go up to Minnesota,
even at that point,
cause he would go and he started talking to my mother.
This one was one poem called,
do you fear the wind to do you?
If you're the force of the wind,
the slash of the rain,
go face it and fight it.
Be Savage again.
I'm going to go cold and hungry like a wolf.
Okay.
I think we're going to Minnesota.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
And,
and you also say in the book,
I knew and as I had always known that I was born to be assaulter
growing up,
you know,
we were and still are an outdoors family hunt,
fish,
shoot.
You know,
I taught gym from the time you were sick.
Jim starts shooting when he's six years old.
I got my first rifle when I was eight years old.
It was a part of a long going tradition from the pioneer,
a pioneer days,
you know,
here's your,
here's your rifle.
Uh,
I loved being an outdoors and I love all of the mechanics of that part of the
world.
And of course
at that time,
post World War II,
you turn on a TV and a weekend and you've got victory at sea and uh,
you know,
Arab power,
an Oldie shows and,
and uh,
um,
I loved military history.
I've watched this stuff and I said I'm going to be a soldier.
And I didn't know at that time really it was a,
it was a close call in high school,
what I would go in the army or what I'd be a marine.
I wanted to do that.
Um,
and when I got to,
I didn't know what college was we do,
it was not part of our family heritage at that time,
you know,
directly go into college and figuring out what school you should go to and those
sorts of things.
So I wouldn't remember when I was 14 years old and my dad and I said,
dad,
I want to,
I want to be a soldier,
says go to college.
I said,
what are you doing in college?
He says,
you're going to be an engineer.
I said,
what an engineer's do.
We said they invent things.
I said,
I don't want to invent anything.
I want to see.
That's right.
I want to go in the woods.
I want to,
I want to lead people.
I know.
And,
uh,
so I,
found out that the,
the Navy had this ROTC scholarship,
this first scholarship full scholarship program because I could not have gotten
the naval academy out of,
out of high school.
My grades weren't that great.
You know,
the other things I had in place,
I think,
uh,
but,
the army did not have an ROTC scholarship at that time.
They had a program where after two years you could get a full scholarship,
but you only had a partial at the beginning.
So I,
I,
uh,
applied to the,
Navy scholarship program.
And at that time,
uh,
you took a standardized test and anybody who passed a standardized tests got
into the interview process and you could go make your case.
So I went was the school that was heavily military kids in the school.
We had 12 people from our school who passed the test and got into the,
the,
uh,
interviews,
our Valedictorian or Salutatorian,
all state basketball player,
all district football player and me.
It's like,
Hey,
pump your gas,
you know,
come see me fight.
And,
uh,
I really lucked out because the two interviewers,
the first one was a Mustang commander,
uh,
who had seen me fight.
And it just totally by coincidence I think it was commander Lasseter.
And he says,
you know,
where have I you before?
And,
uh,
wasn't me.
And I know you talked about what do you want to do?
I said,
I want to do this.
This is what I want to do.
He says,
what are you going to do if you don't get it?
I said,
I'm going to be here next year,
you know,
if you,
if I don't get it this year,
I'll be here next year.
Uh,
and we,
you know,
we talked about working through high school because I worked all through high
school.
Um,
and uh,
he would come after this,
he'd come over,
I was packing groceries at the base comments or he'd come by and say hello.
And uh,
the second interviewer was a naval academy graduate who had graduated and the
bottom two thirds of his class and from South Dakota.
And he,
he,
he was saying,
we don't,
we got enough brains in this world.
We need leaders.
And he through examples out,
you know,
like things you're not supposed to be able to solve.
You probably know those from different interviews and went through and in your
time in the navy.
So he goes,
we got all this mud and the Mississippi River,
what are we going to do about the mud and the Mississippi river?
And I said,
commander,
I've been thinking about this.
I said,
look,
you know,
here's what you do.
You shut that river down for eight hours a day and you run a big,
uh,
like a screen through there,
like a filter,
big filter on,
on a rotator,
a.
And on each end you put like a carwash,
you know,
with the,
the sprays.
And so you run,
you run the filters through and you spray the,
the mud out and you put it in a covert and you get a truck under there.
And I said,
Kevin,
that's topsoil,
send it back up,
you know,
sell it back to the farmers.
So you said,
oh,
I know.
Okay.
And so I got the scholarship.
And uh,
when you,
you mentioned fighting and you mentioned boxing and you know that you mentioned
it a couple of times and,
well obviously I like fighting and uh,
one,
one of the things,
I mean I always,
I,
I'm,
I'm more of a Jujitsu player,
but the things that Jujitsu teaches you about life and about everything really.
And I know a lot of those similar lessons come from boxing.
You had a nice little,
a nice little thing about boxing in here and I just wanted to throw it out there
before we jump too much further because you know,
boxing stays with you through your,
through your,
through your Navel Academy career and whatnot.
But um,
here we go back to the book boxing and Rough Hewn World in which the sport
resided taught me valuable lessons about human struggle and the thin line
between success and failure in the ring.
You quickly learned that life was not always fair and that it's not always offer
you a face saving time out when things were going badly.
Once the bell rang,
you were out there by yourself exposed for all the world to see until it rang
again.
No excuses,
no sitting out for a couple of plays.
Just because somebody hit you so hard,
you couldn't see straight and your toes felt numb.
When,
um,
you know,
my kids would compete in Jujitsu a lot when they were little and I would see
these kids would go to these tournaments in Jujitsu.
Tournaments are very popular,
especially out here in California at that time.
And they're popular everywhere now.
But I would notice that when a kid loses,
you know,
cause my kids played all kinds of sports,
whatever,
soccer and basketball and this and that.
The kid,
if the team loses the soccer game,
the kids,
you know,
they walk off the field when a kid loses a Jujitsu match.
And this is just not just my kids,
but like 90% of kids when they lose that Jujitsu match,
when they're six years old,
when they're seven years old,
they're gonna start crying.
And you know,
it made sense to me instantly.
There's two parts of it that makes sense to me.
Number one,
they're by themselves.
There's no one to blame.
It's not anyone else's fault them team,
it's just them.
And number two,
when you get beat in a con,
in a combat sport,
it's,
there's,
there's a,
a primal thing that you just realize you got beat by another human being in this
game and,
and it's not a game.
And so it's,
it's like you said,
it's like there's no,
there's no way out of it.
And for me,
those lessons that people take away from combat sports are extremely important.
And it's the things that you just talked about right here.
The,
you're absolutely right.
And an on a,
on a number of different levels,
you know.
And one thing about,
well first of all on one thing about judo and Jujitsu,
you know,
when I was a kid,
I used to read a lot and read a lot about Asian history and you learn the,
the Japanese philosophy behind it,
which is to take your opponent's strength and use it against him,
you know?
And it was just a kind of a different thing than boxing.
But I've always thought about that,
you know,
and,
and other areas of,
of,
of my life I've thought about that.
And in terms of a boxing,
you know,
you never know who the judges are.
Uh,
you know what,
you know,
you,
you're,
you're absolutely right.
I mean,
nothing,
nothing is worse than losing when it's just you out there.
If it wants a team out there,
you know,
you've got,
you've got people you can pat on the back and whatever,
but it's just you.
Or as a,
one of the great fighters in Omaha,
when I was fighting,
used to say it's just you and the other guy and all that smoke.
But so you,
you learn to deal with.
And,
you know,
when I say,
you may perceive unfairness,
you know,
you,
you all right.
You know,
I think I won that fight,
but you can't talk about it for the rest of your life.
You just say,
all right,
you gotta you got to swallow it.
And then you got to say that was that.
And the other thing is you have to prepare,
you know,
when you,
when you say I'm going to,
you know,
like 15,
16 years,
I could,
I could be fighting in front of 3000 people,
you know,
Omaha lows.
And then I'm a lot going on in the winter and it was cold and then coming into
the coliseum and watch watch.
And there were good fighters,
you know,
really well my head Almaha good fighters at back then,
including a professional,
uh,
stable as well.
But,
uh,
yeah,
I'm going to be in front of 3000 people and I don't wanna look like an ass,
you know?
And so you put it on yourself,
you put preparation on yourself,
which actually is a great learning tool for being a writer.
You know,
you,
you might think you're working hard or are,
you may think you're just passing the time,
but when the book comes out,
you're going to be exposed to all these reviews and that sort of stuff,
you know.
So,
um,
and also it's kind of interesting cause I was just talking to uh,
a friend of mine who is in,
in government right now who was a very fine football player.
And we were comparing,
he was talking about how,
how hard it was to deal with a certain individual because he'd been a wrestler
and he doesn't understand how,
you know,
you get the team around you to,
to solve these problems.
Well,
you know,
you learned to step forward and take responsibility for solutions.
You know,
if you're an individual sport,
I mean probably more than any other kind of a sport,
you know,
it's like,
alright,
this is what I believe and this is what I'm going to fight for.
And if we lose,
we lose.
But this is what we're going to do.
And in my life,
combining that with,
with the Marine Corps,
you know,
where you are responsible for the lives of other people and you have to make
decisions that affect other people.
There couldn't have been better training for any other leadership situation that
I've been in.
When,
when,
uh,
going back to where you got selected amongst for this,
for this scholarship program,
you,
one thing you said is here,
nobody's going to outwork me to have,
so as I remember the day I got that cause I,
I said okay,
I'm going to wrap myself a little tighter here.
You know,
somebody up there likes me.
I remember that one.
I,
you know when,
uh,
you got the,
the letter from the navy in the mailbox.
If it was a thin little letter,
you knew it was a no you're not.
I got the packet,
it was cold.
I got that pack and I went,
I did this,
you know,
and I am going to bust my tail,
and then who came?
All right.
Ooh.
At back then,
it was like they were 51 schools that had these programs.
And you,
you listed the top six in order and then yes,
no,
yes,
no.
Well,
I go to these others and I'm sitting in Omaha,
Nebraska,
freezing.
I'll go anywhere.
I put down the six warmest schools.
I did not know the University of California from the man in the moon,
but I said university,
California sounds when warm.
And I,
and I put it on the top and I got into University of California.
I mean,
they didn't have their Nebraska quote of the year or something,
I don't know.
And,
uh,
had a great time there,
and did very well in the military program.
And My,
uh,
my marine corps,
the Marine Corps officer in the program said,
you,
you really should go to the academy,
you know,
and so did my dad,
my dad's saw how much fun I was having down there.
We need to lock this boy up,
you know?
And so,
so you applied then for the Naval Academy while you're at USC and it was that,
were you surprised to get in there?
Well.
Um,
I think first of all,
I had,
I had ranked first in the leadership programs at southern cal and I got strong
recommendations,
uh,
major ontercor off where was the,
the marine and,
uh,
and my,
Lieutenant Colburn was the naval instructor and they both wrote strong letters
for me.
Um,
and I had to get letters of recommendation from high school.
And you know,
when I was in high school,
um,
I did really well in the literature programs,
even though I've got put in dummy English,
my city,
my,
my senior year,
you know,
and,
we were like,
what did you do last summer?
While they were studying the great artists,
but the woman who was,
uh,
was my teacher,
she saw how much I loved to write and,
and read and the sort of thing.
And,
uh,
so she wrote me a wonderful letter and had done an a and you know,
I was on the presidential appointment side,
which was the active duty military.
Uh,
uh,
and I think they took,
I can't remember now whether they took 50 or 75,
but they took a certain number from the,
from the country and I got in.
So,
so the,
you know,
the naval academy is a,
is a,
is a story unto itself.
Uh,
you have one section.
I obviously didn't go to the Naval Academy.
Of course I worked with a ton of people over the years that,
that did.
But I,
I thought that this little,
uh,
story,
well,
I just thought it might capture some stuff about the naval academy and I'm going
to read this going again.
This is still from the book.
I heard my country calling
after dinner.
I reported to the room across the hall where the four who had joined evening
come around towards its end,
took turns beating me with a cricket bat.
Touch your toes.
I,
I sir,
I would lean over and touch my toes.
They would hit me swinging the bat as if taking batting practice for slow pitch
softball game.
I would then come to attention and resume my brace,
which is standing at the position of attention beat army.
Sir,
did that hurt web?
No,
sir.
Touch her toes.
I sir,
the bat would connect again.
Beat army,
sir.
Did it hurt?
No,
sir.
Okay.
Touch your toes.
I sir.
The blow would come.
I would straighten up again.
Beat army,
sir.
Did it hurt?
No,
sir.
After they had each hit a couple of slow pitch home runs and it apparently
stopped being fun and their exuberance diminished.
One of them finally told me that if I would simply admit that it hurt,
they would stop beating me,
but for all I knew even this guarantee could have been double.
Think.
If I told them it hurt,
would I really be allowed to leave or would it just bring yet another lecture
and then another round or worse yet did they really want to send me back across
the hallway?
I had already dealt with doctor no pain before dinner.
I did not want to survive the cricket bat only to go back to toothpick,
which was another torture.
They were putting me through the pain.
Actually left my body,
or maybe it was merely my brain's reaction as I would later find out with
marines who were wounded so severely that their nervous systems became
overloaded in shut down so that they could not feel any pain I had.
I had detached myself from the moment it was this as if I was watching myself
from another room.
Did it hurt web?
No Sir.
Just tell us that it hurt.
Idiot.
Did it hurt?
I could hear worry in his voice somehow.
The very abuse that they were now weary of perpetrating had inspired me by
refusing to lose.
I felt that I was somehow winning.
No Sir.
Touch your toes.
Another blow beat army,
sir.
Behind me.
I heard them discussing that the bat had split length wise on my ass.
All right,
get out of here.
Web III,
sir.
So yeah.
What year was this?
1964.
Yeah.
Naval Academy was a different place.
A needless to say,
um,
than it,
than it is now.
Um,
yeah.
When Bob Timberg was writing his book,
Nightingale Song,
we discussed that that incident in one of the comments he made was,
um,
he meaning me,
uh,
was not particularly bitter about it,
but he could still give me the individual's names and I still could,
I'm not going to,
um,
but you know,
the,
the Naval Academy at at that time,
you know,
the pendulum swings in terms of indoctrination and the,
where education fits in and what type of education,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
but that are this class,
the class of 1968,
I'm depending on them in terms of plebe indoctrination had swung very far and it
was by company really.
They words like tribal systems were 36 different companies and some of them were
relatively loose and some of them them were really,
you know,
actually we had a two,
two companies in,
in my class that ran out,
physically ran out more than half of their plebes.
And these were people were highly screened.
I give some details in the book about the number of class Valedictorians,
varsity athletes,
Eagle Scouts,
etc. Which actually when people have asked me,
you know,
what,
what's the great benefit you got out of going to the Naval Academy?
And one thing I said as well,
I knew that I could achieve among these people who had achieved in different
ways in,
in high school than I had.
I learned,
you know,
that I could compete in and that,
why was on the right track attitude and everything.
But this class,
I think we started with 1350 and um,
the first week or two of,
of,
of plebe year when some people resigned,
they allowed a new increments to come in just for very short period of time.
So let's just stick with 1350.
I think we graduated eight 41.
We had the highest attrition rate of any postwar,
a naval academy post World War II Naval Academy class.
Uh,
and there were some really people who would have been fine officers who were run
out for one reason or left.
Uh,
and that time period too,
um,
coincided with the very beginning of the Vietnam War,
the civil rights movement,
a lot of different things that were tearing the country aside.
I can remember coming back from boxing practice in the summer of 1964 and we had
to know the,
one of the rates when you went down on the tables was to know the three top news
stories of the day and they're on the front page with the Gulf of Tonkin
incident in the off of the coast of Hanoi,
the picture of the CEO.
And we were like saying,
okay,
this is,
this is really going to happen.
And we,
the year that I graduated in 1968 was,
was the,
the worst year for American casualties.
Um,
and it also was,
uh,
the year where in April Martin Luther King was killed in June.
The night before we graduated,
Robert Kennedy was assassinated.
It was just an end tobacco,
it up into the tet 68 offensive happened beef right before Martin Luther King
was killed.
So that was just boom,
boom,
boom.
The,
uh,
the last year and different people reacted in different ways,
but I think the majority of the people that I was with there during that period,
it gave us a real seriousness of purpose.
We knew where we were going.
It wasn't going to go away,
particularly for the Marine Corps.
We know all knew that we are going.
Um,
and so,
um,
by the time I graduated,
there was no doubt in my mind where,
where I was going to go.
It was one of the reasons why on FirstClass cruise,
you know,
at,
at the Naval Academy,
you,
it used to be after your first year,
you cruised with the enlisted folks.
You know,
we,
I lived with the snipes on a cvs,
uh,
after my first year.
It was a great learning experience too,
by the way,
to see how hard those guys worked down here.
It hardly ever saw the light of day and they were a trip to,
in a living spaces.
Um,
I remember when they,
you know,
that we had like six or seven mid ship and in as big living space and you know,
they're giving us the dirtiest job.
They could give us a,
you know,
get down in the bilges and scrubbed whether we've saved this for you,
et Cetera.
And I took whatever they want me to do,
man,
I'll do.
And uh,
so I remember the day they accepted me,
we had this first class petty officer who was kind of like the,
the guy there and they had one wall lockers,
four by four wall locker where they kept all of their different types of books
and other supplies
and area.
Okay.
Web come on over here.
And they gave me the combination.
So that logger and then broke out a bottle of booze in a set of boot up to the,
to the mess hall and [inaudible] scored a can of apple juice.
And it came back and we said,
okay,
you know,
you're all right web.
Uh,
and after my third year,
cause I knew I was going to Vietnam.
I said I didn't really like,
like maybe a see the med.
So I signed up for a med cruise,
um,
and got on the Saratoga USS Saratoga.
And I was like,
I,
as I wrote about in this book,
we graduated the morning after the Arab Israeli war of 1967 began.
And so we,
we went to,
we flew to Rota,
Spain,
then out to Suda Bay Crete where the Saratoga came in to pick us up.
Uh,
and they had just met evac.
The USS Liberty.
Uh,
the hangar deck was littered with casualties from the USS Liberty.
And when we,
uh,
when we took the,
the small boats out and start bringing our gear in and,
and got to the hangar deck and,
and there were marine guards around it and they said,
do not talk to any of these people.
And you know,
we went up to our spare 48 of us that were on the Saratoga.
Uh,
we went up to our living spaces and that was an incredible cruise cause the
Soviet Navy had just broken down into the med and we were playing games with
them the whole time.
Uh,
they crossed the deck,
the liberty casualties into the America,
which took them into,
into Athens.
But it was,
you know,
constant air ops on that carrier while we were there.
Incredible learning experience.
Yeah.
That's why if you have it seeing air ops on the aircraft carrier,
the first time that I saw it I was,
it's,
it's insane.
It's what it is.
It's insane.
And that's just normal life on a carrier and you know,
the difference.
Uh,
and same thing I'm talking about my dad and the muscle squad.
The difference back then and now was I had a little eight millimeter movie
camera and you know,
after a evening meal I could go sit on the flight deck and take pictures of
flight ops.
You know,
now you know,
for,
for safety reasons and whatever other reasons you can't do that.
But I've got some great shots of some of the,
you know,
they are a five taken off for those things and we had spans on there and that
whole cruise,
we had a an a four they said with a nuke on it in the front,
right catapult because of the situation that was going on in the Middle East.
So yeah,
that's a,
this is a,
I thought pretty pertinent here is you're,
you're at the academy and this is what you're talking about right now,
but going back to the book as the Vietnam War gathered intensity,
the leadership of the brigade began posting pictures and biographies of alumni
who had been killed,
a war missing in action on a large board in the middle of the Rotunda just
inside the main entrance to Bancroft Hall.
The pictures and short biographies were taken from the lucky bag,
the class year book from the year that each alumnus who graduated the board on
which the notices were placed was large,
perhaps eight feet high and four or five feet wide.
At its top was a boldly lettered inscription to those who went before of us
before us
as the class of 1968 and year of graduation.
The two,
those who went before us board had become two boards.
And then three high percentage of the alumni listed were either marines or naval
aviators.
Many of their names and faces were familiar to all of us,
more than a few included friends.
And some of these were especially close.
So that's a,
that's a reality for everyone there.
Especially because in 1964 that wasn't happening.
And then you go to 1968 and you're filling up this board,
do all but every day.
And look at the,
you know,
you,
you looked to see what the new faces are.
Um,
and the classes of 66 and 67 in the marine corps were hit very hard.
Protect 68.
Uh,
yeah.
And I think I wrote about this,
but I didn't,
one of the,
one of the toughest moments of that period of my life was when I was the brigade
administrative officer.
And so,
you know,
my job,
which wasn't much of a job,
was to go to one of the things was to go to the main office,
clear out all the correspondence in they're sorted out,
pass it to the rest of the brigade staff,
et Cetera.
And one of them was bringing a casualty reps to the brigade first lieutenant who
get the board on and without even a knowing it,
while I picked him up,
I picked up the casually a report of one of my good friends.
Yeah.
And um,
you,
you graduate from the academy and it's time to go to God,
go to comp time to go to the basic school and learn and doing it.
I've talked to her a bit about the base school.
I've had marines on here that went through it.
Uh,
Brian,
Stan and he gave us pretty good details on the basic school and,
but um,
obviously at this time for you,
and I'm going to just going to go to the book for the Marines combat and
overseas deployments were unending.
The greatest burden fell on the privates and lance corporals fresh from bootcamp
who populated the lower ranks of the rifle platoons and the lieutenants just out
of the basic school who commanded them.
The basic school,
which we called TBS,
was now starting a new class of 250 lieutenants every three weeks.
In pre Vietnam days,
TBS had taken 30 weeks to complete as Vietnam accelerated the time a new
lieutenant spent at TBS was reduced to 26 weeks and then to 21 but true to the
traditions of long held disciplines of the core.
This reduction took place not by cutting the quality or the content of the
curriculum by rather by the number of hours spent in class and in the field
every work week.
Almost every week TBS companies worked late into Saturday evening.
They spent a high percentage of their time in the field and a large percentage
of that time was dedicated to night maneuvers and bivouacs.
Our company was given the day off on Christmas,
working late into the evening of December 24th and assembling on the tarmac for
a field activity as zero six 30 in the morning of December 26th.
Within a month of,
within a month after finishing TBS,
the infantry lieutenants among us would be boarding military flights to Travis
Air Force Base,
California to report immediately for 13 month tours in Vietnam as individual
replacements in infantry battalions that were already
engaged in sustained heavy combat.
Well,
of course lemme lemme just say something about,
about the basic school at that time.
Um,
that's probably the best school I've ever been to a day as a,
as I wrote the,
the course got condensed in its time,
but not in the quality of what they were preparing us to do.
Uh,
on the one hand,
the Marine Corps had dropped,
um,
a 60 millimeter mortar out of its,
uh,
Arsenal.
After the Korean War.
They decided that they didn't need it with more artillery,
close air,
et cetera.
They learned early in the Vietnam War that it was a valuable a weapon.
They put the 60 Mike Mike package back into basic school.
So it actually added a tactical package in,
into the basic school curriculum.
They cut out a,
Oh,
some of the dress and ceremony stuff.
You know,
they,
they did,
they did take that stuff out.
Uh,
not,
not all of it,
but what some of it,
but we worked six days a week and we worked.
Yeah,
we worked,
uh,
on the 24th and the 26th of December.
We worked on the 31st and the 2nd of July,
I mean,
of January.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
it was,
I think the intensity actually helped prepare us,
uh,
some of the great friends in my life where people that I,
that I met in basic school,
we were constantly together.
And by doing this every day,
you know,
in intensely every day,
uh,
you got a better feel for what you actually were going to be required to do.
The interesting thing about basic school,
one of the reasons I say it was the best school I've ever been to was,
um,
it was educational,
it was practical and it was looking toward the future friends,
any weapons system.
And we,
we learn every weapon in the infantry battalion.
In basic school.
They would teach it to you in class,
then you would walk out and assemble,
disassemble,
familiarize it,
and then you would go shoot it every single weapon.
Um,
my,
uh,
first my first night as a rifle platoon commander,
I took the platoon that I had just picked up into a night,
move a night ambush and hit a north Vietnamese unit with a 51 cal machine gun.
Used every supporting arm in the Marine Corps except for close air.
Uh,
very first patrol,
did all the on calls,
et Cetera.
And you know,
that was basic school.
Um,
so they,
did they go out?
How did they run problems with you in the field during the basic school?
Would they take her out on patrol?
They have opt for brands.
They would attack you planes.
Um,
we ran close there.
There weren't any planes attacking us and it's the same Vietnam.
Oh,
no,
no.
I said,
I said role players.
So when you would,
when you're doing a patrol in the basics,
oh,
I see.
How did you simulate and how well did they simulate it?
Some of it was,
was a walkthrough.
You know,
you would start with the walkthroughs.
Um,
first of all,
we had,
we had really talented,
uh,
combat experienced instructors and all of our,
where platoons brook or a company is broken down to five pollutants
alphabetically.
You know,
you know how that works when you're sort of at the end of the alphabet.
we've got the worst gear,
the last in line for everything.
And I can remember one night we were getting dismissed or in a company
formation.
And,
uh,
one of the,
it was a former enlisted,
uh,
marine and our platoon,
we were Robert's through Zell something,
you know,
and he's,
he just started yelling at this fucking zoo.
And from that point for a lot of times when we'd March and we would go to zoo
zoo.
Uh,
but we had,
you know,
our,
uh,
staff platoon commander had been seriously wounded as a rifle platoon commander
in fifth marines.
Um,
you know,
all of,
all of our po step tune commanders had,
had been,
uh,
in,
in combat.
Uh,
there were a lot of talks,
you know,
those sorts of things.
Um,
but then on the tactics side,
you'd go out,
you'd learn it,
you know,
you learned it in class.
You could go out and walk through it,
and then you'd have aggressors.
[inaudible] we're a SDT.
You called Stt,
aggressors,
which were,
uh,
enlisted marines just back from Vietnam who just loved to mess with the,
with the,
the basic school lieutenants,
the big problem.
And the greatest surprise,
I have to say,
uh,
in,
in moving into combat,
the big problem was if,
if you're a say for this exercise,
if you're the platoon commander on this platoon,
in the attack exercise,
you've got 49 other lieutenants sitting near Saint.
No,
but I can do it that way.
five ya'll come,
man,
you know,
there's no,
which you don't need to be online.
We need to be in a wedge,
you know,
or you know,
you need to,
whatever,
whatever.
You know,
and I will never forget the feeling of actually commanding a rifle platoon in
combat and being on the move.
And I just said,
hold it up and everything just stopped,
you know,
that we're just right now,
boom.
I mean,
when that is,
everybody stopped,
you know,
and I went,
wow,
this is pretty good.
But uh,
you know,
the,
there were,
there were things that could have been taught better.
The one thing is,
uh,
one of the things that I am very proud of in terms of the way that we did
operate in Vietnam,
we had had a lot of leeway to innovate.
It's,
that's kind of been lost I think in the,
in the history of it.
Um,
and there were,
I mean,
it's in letters.
I wrote back to officers that I knew talking about,
you don't really,
you didn't,
you have a petroleum package over here and you've got a platoon attack package
over here.
But really what we do all the time is we patrol.
Then we assembled.
Then we attack.
Or if we're going to go into a built up area is from the uh,
the uh,
uh,
section.
You read the expert you read from,
from fields of fire.
You know,
I know when to go online.
I know when to put my troops on.
I know where to put my guns.
Uh,
that didn't come from,
from basically a school.
The separate,
the separate entities did.
We connected it in the,
in,
in the reality of,
of,
of what we were doing.
And I'll tell you there's a long line,
we're getting a little ahead of things,
but they're there.
There's a long line of things that,
uh,
the young leaders in Fifth Marines had done before I got there.
And,
and also in what I was able personally to do as a rifle platoon in particularly
as a,
as a company commander.
One of the things we saw,
and I wrote an article about this concept when I got back from Vietnam,
was that the Marine Corps fire team,
this is,
this is simple and small,
but it really is,
you know,
institutionally,
uh,
important,
the Mokoro fire teams for four Marines.
It was built around the bar Browning automatic rifle.
It had,
it had,
it had a been put into place in,
in World War II because at the beginning of World War II,
the marine reigns only operated with squats like 1111 marine squat.
And they found that a squadron couldn't control directly control 11 people.
So they went into the triangular concept with the,
you know,
the former marine fire teams.
Uh,
but the problem with that was if you took two casualties,
you don't have a maneuver element.
And it is built around an artificial notion because the [inaudible] could be
fully automatic.
You know,
I had,
I kept some in fourteens in my platoon as well.
Um,
so what,
what the,
the young leaders in a,
in a fifth marines just sort of over time,
start,
uh,
doing,
was cannibalizing the third rifle squad.
Uh,
and so in,
in our rifle platoon,
instead of having three rifles,
squads,
and in a,
in a gun team attached from this notional weapons platoon,
we put,
uh,
the rifleman into two squads.
Uh,
and then brought the gun team in as the third squad for the triangular concept.
and that just kind of happened,
you know,
uh,
no one told us to do it.
We just said,
you know,
you can't,
with the casualties casualty flow that we were taking,
you just couldn't do it,
uh,
any,
any other way and be effective with the fire teams has maneuver elements.
Um,
we moved at night,
constantly.
Fifth Marines.
We moved at night.
We were known from moving at night.
We walked when we moved for the helicopter assets,
uh,
in,
in Vietnam for the Marine Corps were scarce to the h 46 was,
was built to standards from,
uh,
amphibious carrier's and Fibia assault ships.
So they were built to deck space,
um,
and you know,
for amphibious assaults.
But then when you get an as continuous ground operation,
there just weren't enough of them and they were very vulnerable to ground fire.
Uh,
so in,
in areas where the army would have been,
you know,
picking up with,
uh,
you know,
a,
a Huey,
you know,
getting breakfast and getting on a huge reason.
I'm not running him down.
This was a great concept,
that air mobile concept.
Uh,
and,
and moving in on,
on areas we walk,
we have,
we had for a long,
long time.
We had two h 46 is for our,
uh,
entire sector during the day,
you know,
resupply or medivacs,
whatever.
So we had a lot of walking.
Uh,
it,
it taught,
it taught you how to fight at night,
but also when something happened to casualties were high because your ass
asshole to belly button when you're walking along,
you know,
um,
if you could,
uh,
you know,
we,
it was not,
not an uncommon practice.
They get a booby trap and IED go off and you get an ambush on it at night,
you know,
your people are packed in,
uh,
at et cetera.
But,
uh,
and 60,
Mike,
Mike Mortar,
um,
I decided,
I,
there were people who taught us as a company,
tactics in basic school district.
60 millimeter mortar is the company commander's personal weapon.
So I decided when I was a company commander,
I would get sent and I liked this.
I would get sent,
you know,
wait away at the edge of our battalions sector kind of operating independently.
But I,
I'd fire sometimes 600 pounds a day and I'd send a,
a a rifle platoon end to secure an area when we're on the move,
you know,
payment,
combat patrol to get a new spot,
send a rifle,
platoon insecurity or I take a resupply,
haven't dropped a pallet [inaudible] hundred rounds.
No,
no,
see that was the old,
that was the tradition beforehand.
Yeah,
you can,
you can hump maybe 40 rounds,
you know.
Uh,
but I'd have him drop a pallet in and have them build to sandbag a of parapet
areas for the 16 weeks to the t o was three.
We kept two and I use him for prep fires.
I use them for h and eyes.
Uh,
you know,
we,
and,
and I,
my guys got really,
really good.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
the,
the mortar teams I've been out in the field with,
uh,
with,
the Marine Corps when they,
you watch those guys set up and fire mortars,
you know,
just in training and it's ridiculous how good they are.
It's awesome thing to watch.
It's a beautiful thing to watch.
Yeah.
The reason I kind of dug in a little bit about the training because when I came
back from my,
from my last deployment to Ramadi,
I took over the training.
And so it was,
it was all that,
that's all all I was trying to do was getting guys ready for what they were
about to face.
And we had,
we had this incredible opportunity,
you know,
we had this,
um,
you ever heard of miles gear and such?
Yeah.
So we had something that wasn't miles gear.
It was like miles gear,
but it was infinitely better.
It was super high speed.
Multimillion dollar system has little speakers on your shoulders.
So when you were getting shot at,
you'd hear snaps from these little speakers or you'd get mortared.
And there'd be explosions going off in your ears.
It was,
it was awesome.
they actually had a,
the very beginning of that concept when we went live fire early on where they
had targets would pop up.
And when she did the target with that was the most sophisticated we get in.
What I found with live fire was my fire.
Cause when I came in it was all we do everything live fire and that was the big
deal.
And we still,
we never got away from lab live fire,
but we added to it this whole force on force training where you're going against
guys with either with lasers,
with paint balls and that was infinitely more realistic because the paper
targets never maneuvered on you.
And same thing when you had the,
the guys returning from Vietnam who were maneuvered on you and you were at the
basic school.
I had all my seals that had just come back from combat deployments and they were
the guys that were going against the platoons that were getting ready to deploy.
So it's uh,
it was awesome.
And I would get,
the feedback I would get was always,
hey,
it was,
it was actually easier in combat,
you know,
minus the,
the actual death,
but the,
the threat of actual death,
the maneuvering that would happen,
you know,
they were used to maneuvering against seals who were bad ass and now they're
maneuvering against someone else.
It's not quite as,
you know,
in the game.
And also the enemy doesn't know our tax as well as we know it.
So my guys would know the tactics that there was going to be used against him.
So it was,
uh,
it was awesome.
But it's just when you talk about showing up in Vietnam and,
and your first patrol,
you're going out and you're in that and you handle it,
that's,
that's a complete testament to the quality of that training because it's
freaking crazy.
Well,
you know,
I think when we were talking about this last night,
attitude development is the key to everything,
you know,
and getting your mind right as in terms of what you're going to do.
And um,
uh,
knowing the,
that are available.
And,
you know,
I spent a lot of time thinking about this too,
uh,
in terms of what,
what I was going to face to eye,
I had a,
I had one really terrific mentor.
Um,
uh,
when I graduated from the Naval Academy,
I spent like two months as a drill officer at the,
at the end with the new class coming in before we reported to,
to basic school.
And I was a battalion drill officer.
There were six of us,
there were six battalions.
I got the marine battalion officer who had just gotten out of the hospital from,
had been wounded and content.
It was a company commander,
Alpha one one.
And uh,
he was terrific.
Bill Stenson was his name and uh,
you know,
he'd been shot,
he'd been blown up and,
and he was like so easy.
I mean,
no bullshit,
easy,
um,
and easy as a leader.
And so the other,
the other five drill officers in my class,
they,
they got their own office,
you know,
with their battalion officer.
And Stensilan goes,
why do you need an office?
He said,
you know,
so you're a lieutenant,
now you get an office,
why do you need an off?
Why don't you just sit in my office?
So I'd sat in his office and every day was like,
you know,
talking back and forth,
and I'd go out and I do,
you know,
lunch,
I go do my four miles and do all my stuff.
And he'd come back and he said,
what are you doing?
That's all.
I'm,
I'm getting ready to go to Vietnam.
He says,
you would've noticed like in Vietnam,
he said,
I'm going to take you out tonight and we're going to get really,
really drunk and I'm going to keep you up all night.
And then tomorrow you're going to work.
That's what it feels like.
And he did,
you know,
in the next day it was like,
aw man,
please don't talk so loud,
sir.
And then,
uh,
before I,
before I left,
one of the things I,
you know,
I talked to him about four,
I left for basic school.
I said,
what did it feel like to get shot at?
And he goes,
look,
don't even think about that stuff.
I mean it's just,
you know,
forget about that stuff.
Just do your job.
You know,
and I was the very first thing I thought about when I took that that patrol out.
I could hear a stunt,
someone gone,
just don't even think about that stuff.
You know,
I'm going to take it to the book here for a minute cause uh,
well this is the chapter called Helen,
this very small place and it talks about exactly what you're saying here.
So back to the book.
From the day of my arrival as platoon commander with dying Delta,
we had been engaged in continuous combat operations,
intensified in recent weeks by a series of unpredictable vicious firefights
despite a steady flow of individual replacements.
The numerical field strength of our rifle company had been reduced by about half
over the past three months.
This was an equal opportunity battlefield.
We lost marines through every possibility that infantry combat offered,
including gunshot wounds from several different caliber weapons,
all kinds of shrapnel,
large caliber rockets,
rocket propelled grenades,
RPGs,
different sorts of hand grenades,
61 and 82 millimeter mortar fire recoilless rifles plus landmines of every size
from a grenade to large caliber artillery shells.
The rifle platoons were largely made up of young both officers and enlisted by
1969 the vaunted ranks of the career and staff Nco.
Those who historically been the backbone of the Marine Corps.
We're showing the effects of four years of heavy combat in the infantry
battalions.
That impact was both visible and profound within a few days of my,
within a few days,
my platoon sergeant,
the fourth marine,
to hold this key position in the past three months would leave us a severe case
of ringworm covering his torso,
including his entire crotch area up front and back.
My first platoon sergeant had been hit by a booby trap while maneuvering one
segment of our platoon onto original line during an extensive firefight,
suffering,
suffering shrapnel wounds in his hands and arms and stomach area,
blowing off pieces of his fingers and slicing his bladder.
The second platoon sergeant had served with us for a couple of weeks and then
was sent by the company commander to another unit.
The third had picked up his third purple heart after being hit by an RPG and
thus had been rotated out of Vietnam.
The fifth on his second Vietnam tour became sick of the constant combat and
suddenly decided to leave the Marine Corp and our rifle company when his
enlistment expired.
Toward the end of this very operation.
In practical terms,
this turbulence intensified the relationships between the platoon commanders in
the squad leaders as daily life and death.
Tactical decisions would need needed to be made in these relationships.
I often ended up being the oldest and most wizened voice at the age of 23 I was
now on my fourth platoon radio operator,
who within weeks would be shot through his elbow,
ending his days in the Marine Corps.
Two months before in April,
I had lost two radio operators in one day.
The first shop through that the hand by the end by an enemy sniper as he held
the receiver of our PRC 25 radio in the middle of a firefight.
Luckily for our platoon,
if not for him,
his handed partially shielded the radio handset which survived the bullet.
Otherwise,
we would have been isolated surrounded by hundreds of mobile and highly adept
enemy soldiers on combat patrols.
That ranged far away from our company headquarters.
The tactical radio was our sole means of communicating our position and to call
in artillery support and medivacs.
This of course was why the enemy loves to shoot at it.
An hour later,
the second radio operator had been blown off.
His feet hit below the knees in both legs by a booby trap.
As we assaulted a ridge radio operators did not have much luck in my platoon.
By the time I left the platoon,
I had gone through six.
Two of my original three squad leaders had been killed,
one by an enemy rocket and the other from a gunshot wound to the chest.
The third had been shot through the lung and in the liver during the onset of an
enemy ambush.
Although grievously wounded,
he had survived the fire fight and was later medivac to a navy hospital ship.
And so it had been for the officers who had initially staffed our rifle company.
The first platoon commander had been killed three weeks before.
The second platoon commander had been lightly wounded.
Less than two weeks before,
and within the next few weeks would suffer a serious gunshot wound in his upper
thigh.
A bullet narrowly missing it and artery.
I had been lightly wounded and would be seriously wounded a month later.
Well,
let's set the stage.
Um,
let's start the final a couple of days in and basic school because one of the
most important,
uh,
what's a speech?
But one of the most important speeches that I had listened to during my
preparation time was given that,
and there was a burrito lieutenant colonel,
uh,
who was assigned to the basic school who asks to talk to the infantry
lieutenants.
We had to think s it's somewhere in the 70s of our 243 who finished basics,
who all were assigned to the infantry.
And
the sky was highly respected.
He had been,
uh,
an enlisted marine or rifleman,
well Jima.
He had been a platoon commander in Korea,
recipient of the navy cross,
and had just finished commanding a battalion in Vietnam.
And he said,
I,
I want you to understand something.
Vietnam is the hardest war the marine corps has ever fought,
not simply because of the casualties,
which by the way ended up being higher even than World War II if you combine
killed and wounded,
more killed in World War II.
Um,
but because of the living conditions that,
that these marines are facing,
um,
were you,
at this excerpt you were reading was sort of in the middle of an,
of an operation?
Uh,
in addition to those types of,
of,
uh,
experiences people rarely understand in,
in America the America of then and particularly in America to have today for
what it was like to be in the marine infantry in Vietnam.
Tickly of all of them put particularly out in [inaudible] province were we
fought.
Um,
the marines fought in five provinces,
uh,
in,
in Vietnam.
Um,
Kwong tree,
which is where case on and,
uh,
up next to the DMC,
to attend,
which has worked way,
was,
uh,
quite numb.
I would west of Denang,
we're where we fought,
uh,
in a quiet and shy and quiet tin was also a province then.
It's not a province now,
but a plurality and almost a majority of the marines killed in Vietnam were
killed in [inaudible] province.
And I can't give you a really major battle.
I mean,
there's some,
uh,
operations that are notable in sort of Marine Corps law,
but you know,
no one in the country would,
would even recognize them.
These were squad platoon company size engagements.
Um,
and we're the constant,
constant combat activity.
Uh,
and where the marines operated,
we're usually outside of anything.
We didn't have tents,
Barb wire,
we didn't have cots,
we didn't have electricity,
didn't have hot food,
didn't have clean water.
Uh,
it was an extraordinarily rough environment in terms of hygiene,
potential disease and just the wear and tear foot put on human bodies.
So you put that on top of the combat side.
And then on top of what you had mentioned earlier,
which is the constant flow of people through the apparatus that was the combat
unit and the political tensions.
And in the country you put all that together,
you have a very,
very tough,
uh,
environment where,
where the marines lived and also where the young leaders operated.
Um,
so,
you know,
when I'm taking over a rifle platoon,
uh,
in,
that area called Anwar Basin,
um,
I'm just off the plane.
You know,
we've graduated from basic school at 10 days,
travel 10 days,
proceed a little bit of leave,
get on the plane,
um,
go through Okinawa for,
uh,
you know,
to kind of get your,
your,
uh,
time zones straight.
And then I didn't even know what regiment over division I was going to.
When I hit Vietnam Day,
you,
we got to uh,
um,
actually an on Okinawa.
They decided whether you,
which division you were going to go to.
Okay,
we're looking at the casualty flow.
You guys,
you're going to third MAR DIV,
you guys,
you're on the first smart.
If,
uh,
and then when you got to done ang headquarters of the first marine division,
they would kind of sort us out to which,
which regiment we were going to a regimen.
They say,
okay,
you're going to first battalion or first battalion.
I said,
Delta Delta needs a platoon commander.
Um,
and get on a convoy,
take off the,
the,
the company had been through some,
you know,
some serious combat and the previous days I think they'd had five platoon
commanders and the previous five or six months.
Uh,
so Diane Gunther was the,
where was the nickname?
Yeah.
Is that like a derogatory or was that just gallows humor?
We kind of liked it.
You just got a deadly dying Delta or dog tired Delta,
whatever.
But you're constantly on the move.
Um,
and you know,
I'm new and they are justifiably,
they're gone.
Oh man,
here we got a new guy here.
Now what?
Um,
and there's always in the realm of leadership,
the,
the relationship that you have to put into place and you don't,
you know,
some,
some people like to say like to say,
okay,
when lieutenant comes in,
you can be like the observer for a while and go along and patrol.
And what rarely did those people ever fully take over their platoon?
You're the ready or you're not ready.
And so I,
and I,
I picked up my platoon,
I got them on a side of a hill and I explain,
you know,
did you insert into the field to take home over?
Did you,
did you go right into the foyer?
They were on the move that we're on the move from liberty bridge,
the Henderson Hill on a company move the convoy pass by.
I jumped off the convoy,
I talked on the radio to our,
our,
our company commander,
you know,
before,
um,
and I didn't even get three days in Ann Wass.
I'm,
you know,
usually at three days in a handoff for familiar racing.
He said,
this,
this guy's class aren't a mentor and basic school.
Get 'em out here now and a,
so I took these guys overhead,
I'm on the side of the hill and I said,
you know,
this is Bob Tinbergen is booked at Nightingale song called us and audition for a
fragging.
I said,
uh,
all right,
I'm Lieutenant Webb,
you call me lieutenant or you call me Sir and this is what I expect.
And I laid it all out,
you know,
and uh,
and one of the things I said,
which I think is very important,
and when you're,
when you're leading anything,
I said,
I want you to know something.
Anything you tell me,
I will believe anything.
You tell me,
the sky's Brown.
I'll believe you.
And if you lie to me,
you're dead meat.
And so there was like,
the hell does this guy think he's doing,
you know?
And then we went out that night,
you know,
and I sat down,
I planned it,
we,
we moved to the new perimeter.
I went in,
I called my squad leaders together,
company size,
perimeter,
company size perimeter.
Um,
I've got,
I've got my squad leaders NSI and we've got an IDAC and we're going to go here
and,
uh,
think it was a few locks.
Um,
you know,
got their input.
Listen,
listen,
listen.
You always listened.
You know,
being the commander doesn't mean you know,
all the answers.
It,
it means you don't have to make a decision,
you know,
and,
and how to,
how to follow through.
Um,
and,
uh,
so I figured it out.
Can I listen to them?
I figured out a place where we would go.
Uh,
I had a really terrific squad leader who was actually acting platoon commander
that afternoon.
Um,
and set a series on calls,
bid over.
You know,
cause I'm thinking the basic school taught you went out that night,
walked in,
you know,
walked into a situation,
used all the,
you know,
the supporting arms,
did our,
did our thing,
and that was put to rest,
which was actually a good thing.
And then the other thing,
which I think is so important,
you know,
when you say,
know your people,
know,
you know,
what's the leadership.
Leadership is knowledge.
Know your people,
know your job,
know their job and know the next job because you never know when something's
going to happen and you're going to have that next job.
And it's character.
And part of part of character is consistency and humility before your people,
you know,
and as you mentioned from what the excerpt about my dad,
moral courage,
there's different kinds of courage.
Moral courage is sometimes you've got to take the hits,
you got to lay out what you believe is right and you got to stay with it.
Um,
and you know,
vision,
in other words,
what even taking over a rifle platoon,
you know,
they,
they knew fairly quickly.
I knew what I was expecting even though I hadn't done it yet.
Uh,
but knowledge of people and listening to people.
I would go in and one of the first,
you know,
month or so that I was a platoon commander,
I would take three hours to set my lines in every night,
sit down every fighting hole,
talk to every one of my marines.
And you find out as,
you know,
you find out really interesting things about maybe simple things like somebody
hadn't gotten paid or somebody got married and had a Q a Lot,
must not going to his wife and nobody's taken kip.
Just simple things,
you know.
Um,
and then,
uh,
you know,
then the bonds move from there.
Uh,
you,
you just,
just to reiterate the conditions,
cause I,
I pulled out this,
this section in here where you talk about the conditions and just to reiterate
what you're talking about,
going back to the book here in,
in the rifle companies,
we spent endless months patrolling ridge lines and villages and mountains far
away from tense barbed wire.
Hot food or electricity luxuries were limited to what we could fit inside one's
pack,
which after a few humps usually boiled down to letter writing,
material towel,
soap,
toothbrush,
Poncho liner,
and a small transistor radio due to casualties and disease.
During this period in the war,
relatively few marines would actually survive a full 13 month tour as members of
rifle companies in the Bush of the basin,
we move through the boiling heat carrying 60 pounds of weapons in gear causing a
typical marine to drop 20% of his body weight while in the bush.
When we stopped,
we dug chest deep fighting holes and slit trenches for toilets.
We slept on the ground under makeshift Poncho hooches and when it rained we
usually took down our hooches because wet poncho shown under illumination flares
making great targets.
Sleep itself was fitful never more than an hour or two at a stretch for months
at a time as we mixed daytime patrolling with nighttime ambushes,
listening posts,
foxhole duty and radio watches,
ringworm,
hookworm,
malaria dysentery were common as was trench foot,
which in Vietnam was called immersion foot.
When the monsoons came,
re respites for was rotating back to the mud filled regimental combat base at
and Hawaii for four or five days where rocket and mortar attacks were frequent
and our troops man defensive bunkers at night,
that was your break time.
And Wa
they called it little d and Ben food there,
you know,
because yeah,
they had a son that's actually welcomed the little deal.
Then food and you know,
at least they kept their sense of humor to vertically all the first,
you know,
how people,
gallows humor,
here's what gets you through that kind of stuff.
Um,
and,
and to sort of set the tone of the,
um,
uh,
on the,
on the tactical side,
do you need to remember in terms of what was happening to the country at this
time?
This was a award that hadn't been going on and it had its controversies,
but hundreds of people were dying every week,
still every week.
Um,
I brought this,
and I know we're not on TV,
but I brought this,
there's like a circle once the audio,
you know,
you're,
you're welcome to keep us and make copies of it if you would send it back to me.
But this was the cover of life magazine.
June 27th night,
June 27th,
1969.
Average week in this,
during this period,
this was the period of hamburger hill,
et cetera.
The,
uh,
242 Americans died that week.
Two of,
of our marines are in,
in that.
Um,
but,
uh,
in a post,
a post [inaudible] 69 period,
which was April,
May,
um,
we were losing more than 400 Americans dead a week.
Uh,
you know,
even though the warhead for the Americans in casual,
he's had peaked in 1968.
The,
the three worst years for combat for the Americans,
Vietnam were 67,
68 and 69.
They're like the top of the bell curve.
Um,
we had an in in 69,
I think we lost twice as many Americans killed as have been killed in Iraq and
Afghanistan and the entire war.
Uh,
and you know,
the American people supported this and I've always believed in what we were
attempting to do,
however,
are screwed up it got.
But if you're out here in the,
uh,
in the [inaudible] basin,
um,
the one thing that a good rifle platoon or company commander or a battalion
commander learned was how to adapt,
how to adapt.
You couldn't rarely,
you could rarely plan,
uh,
operations.
Um,
you know,
sort of like,
like Mike Tyson said about being in a fight.
Everything is great until the first time you get hit,
you know,
uh,
on any given patrol,
or,
or day in San Juan Basin,
particular in Arizona Valley,
you could hit,
you know,
some idiot with not idiot.
So maybe some smart,
smart individual or small group of people with a couple of grenades.
Or You could hit a main force Viet Cong unit,
which was heavily north Vietnamese,
or you could hit a large for large force,
a north Vietnamese.
We fought in in May of 1968 and [inaudible] nine,
we fought with the 90th regimen in the Arizona Valley and went on for eight days
and,
and eight nights.
We had a north Vietnamese division and base area one 12,
right off from where we were,
the,
the mountain started,
uh,
up into Laos where the coachman and trail and that sort of thing.
Uh,
we had,
uh,
a very fine of Viet Cong Regiment,
which was,
you know,
rather rare that an independent regiment,
the first VC regimen,
uh,
we had to Qa,
third main force force battalion that we're operating out of the Arizona Valley.
And then you had a lot of cats and dogs.
And the other thing was this area basically been written off by my American war
planners in terms of the,
the,
uh,
politicization,
you know,
they're bringing into the south Vietnamese government at that time.
They categorized villages until categorized villages,
um,
a through e,
uh,
in terms of loyalty to the South Vietnamese government.
A was totally loyal.
He was totally the other way.
And then they had category five,
which was politically hopeless,
just for credit.
And,
uh,
by 1958,
you know,
the,
the country was divided in 1954.
And knowing that people came south,
including my wife's entire family,
not very many,
what north,
basically Kadri went north and they trained.
And starting in 1958,
they started moving back into central Vietnam.
The Haute humans idea was to,
whoever was doing his planning was,
was to cut off central Vietnam first.
Anom uh,
and so you had these assassination squads move into,
into this area.
Uh,
and by 1961,
they were killing 11 government officials,
uh,
day.
Uh,
and that was by John Kennedy's,
uh,
account when he decided to start increasing our,
our troops there.
So the villages had had their fights,
uh,
beginning 58 heavily 58 to 62,
that time period.
And,
uh,
those who are staying with,
with the communist basically had kicked out the people who weren't a lot of move
to Danang and some of them later to Saigon.
So out where we were.
I say this because operationally the populated villages that we,
uh,
that we operated in,
you know,
they had big family bunkers.
They were very,
uh,
you know,
there was stoic when we went through there,
people were up in the mountains.
Uh,
we had,
we had a no illusions that they were going to be moving to our,
our side at least during the,
you know,
I never thought the world was going to end the way that it did,
but at least during the period that we were there,
I,
we were chatting about this a little bit before,
but I wanted to call out this won't one point from the book.
Um,
almost every marine who has ever fallen close combat can relay a stories of
short round stray rounds,
misdirected shots,
accidental discharges and other chaos resulting from friendly fire mortars.
Artillery in airstrikes can easily wander from their intended targets,
sometimes due to map error and other at,
at other times because of human error.
Historically friendly fire incidents during mobile close combat operations make
up about 10% of casualties.
Intramural fire fights can break out among of friendly units that misidentify
their fellow infantry men,
particularly while moving through enemy terrain at night.
And you got one incident that you call up the ch 46 helicopter approach to the
perimeter,
ready to drop our day's load to Huey gunships circle overhead flying for cover
behind highly vulnerable resupply helicopter,
which would soon be hovering above the battlefield and slowly descending into
the small dirt clearing we had scraped out to make a landing zone.
At the center of our perimeter.
The strobe light flashed showing the pilot where to land,
but circling in the weed beds,
one of the gunships mistook the strobe light for the tracer bullets of an enemy
machine gun.
The Huey immediately powered toward us in a low attack line that came in just
above our heads.
Strafing are weary,
beleaguered preliminar perimeter.
It's machine guns spitting out hundreds of seven,
six two millimeter bullets.
I had just climbed a small sand dune to urinate at an empty spot away from the
perimeter.
Poncho hooches and radios of my platoon command post,
but he was machine guns sprayed back and forth inside our lines,
kicking up a trail of dust spots just below my feet.
As I stood in the open after one pass,
the Huey was finally waved away back into,
it's circling defensive laps around our perimeter exposed as we were.
It seemed a miracle that only one marine radio operator near the strobe light in
our company command post was hit taking a bullet in the stomach.
Well I,
it's
one among among many and when you're,
when you're fighting so,
so close,
uh,
you know,
and actually that that incident occurred not too long after an arc light strike.
We were doing the BDA on an arc light.
Um,
it was one of the great ironies.
If I might,
may digress just a little bit,
cause I think it's important to point out that in our operational concepts,
we never used a B 52 is north of then we never until 1972,
the Christmas bombing,
uh,
of,
of Hanoi.
Um,
and when I go back,
I've been back to Vietnam 28 at the last 29 years.
I speak Vietnamese.
I,
you know,
uh,
we,
we still have our disagreements,
but,
uh,
you know,
I go back there and when I first started going back to the Vietnam,
uh,
in the early nineties,
everybody wanted to talk about that eight days.
Everybody,
you know,
when they did this and they were living under the illusion that they were
withstanding American air power when we had these light aircraft,
like John Mccain's aircraft coming in and,
you know,
making the runs when,
if somebody had made a different decision.
I mean,
a war is a war.
If somebody made a different decision,
things might've,
might've happened differently.
But we did use arc lights on the area that we supposedly we're,
we're trying to salvage,
you know,
go Noi island.
Um,
you know,
we lit that place up.
We were,
uh,
our,
our company was,
I think three clicks away.
When,
when that,
when that arc light landed and I was holding onto the ground,
move into the right and to the left,
you know,
um,
how many,
how many pounds of bombs would get dropped her and run.
I've got some statistics in there,
but just thousands and thousands of pounds of,
of uh,
you know,
three,
three 50 be 50 twos would go over.
And actually I think in there,
I put the number,
I uh,
but um,
you know,
so,
but,
uh,
to the,
the friendly fire incidents and how close it was,
um,
you know,
we,
the way that we would mark,
um,
our areas when we're,
when you're unclos hair in that environment,
uh,
you know,
this isn't about the helicopter hitting our,
our guy that was a,
you know,
mistaking the strobe for a machine gun round.
But in general,
you always run your air strikes parallel to your lines because you don't want
them to drop short,
you know,
and drop on you.
So they have to make a run,
you know,
in May.
And we put air panels out.
Usually sometimes we pop a smoke,
but it's better with their air panels during the day.
Um,
and,
uh,
so they knew they'd make a run before they drop.
And,
uh,
so they,
you know,
they'd say,
okay,
yeah,
no,
you're too close.
No,
you're not,
or whatever.
And,
uh,
we had one in,
during this period where we were fighting the 90th regiment out there in Arizona
Valley and May,
we were running and our strike,
uh,
against an NBA unit and a tree line,
but 400 meters away.
And we had at force coming in,
you know,
an air force,
a fire.
It's not a bomber.
I mean,
we use them for bombers,
but,
uh,
so the f four pilots,
they're coming in at,
I don't know,
450 knots,
whatever it is,
and they're there looking out the side of their window to see,
to see what's on the ground.
So we were running the,
uh,
the air force.
I had,
my platoon actually was,
uh,
we had rear security and the perimeter while they were doing this.
And,
um,
they made their run.
And then they came on the second run and the the F four drop dos.
And uh,
it actually,
it bounced right outside our perimeter.
And then,
you know,
what the hell,
I hear it,
I hear it going right over the top of us.
So I turned around and I start,
you know,
I want to go into the company CP and ask him what the hell is going on.
So I'm walking through the scramble of Bushes and they always marines running,
running the other way.
And this thing had bounced and we call it a snake.
And Nape,
you know,
the,
the snake was the,
the way,
uh,
like I kind of a propeller would break out of the tail to arm it when you,
when you're adopted.
And luckily the,
the tail had broken off of this bond when it hit.
And,
uh,
so,
but you know,
I turned around and these guys,
you know,
I see this thing flying through the air.
I thought it was a body,
you know,
it was this green thing flying through the air and going down to word the,
or the CP.
And I'm going in and all these guys are running the other way.
And,
and that bomb had,
had landed on the pack of our 80 ones fo artillery radio operator.
I mean pack those PAC board,
you know,
uh,
dead center if that thing had gone off curtains,
you know.
Uh,
and the other thing is night moves.
You know,
we're,
one of the things you learn is in,
in,
uh,
when you,
when you operate like the Fifth Marines did,
is always be responsible for the person behind you,
not the person in front of you.
Uh,
if you lose the person in front of you,
stop.
Don't try to catch up with them because there,
there were a number of friendly fire incidents where someone would get lost,
uh,
try to catch up and up to the,
on the flank of,
of the,
the main unit and you'd have an intramural firefight.
Luckily we didn't have that happen in my company,
but it happened,
uh,
in the,
in the fifth marines.
So you stop if you can't find the,
see the guy in front of you,
stop.
And then if then,
if you can't see the person behind you,
then you retrace the exact,
a route that you've been on to go pick them up.
Um,
so,
you know,
there were lessons that were learned and put into place.
Yeah.
We,
we,
we always talk about the fact that my life was my buddy's platoon commander,
uh,
with me.
He wrote books with me.
But,
um,
he was saying,
you know,
if you had asked him before he went to Ramadi,
if we would have blue on blue,
you know,
fratricide situations,
he'd been like,
oh,
there's no possible way.
And me,
same thing,
you know,
like it seemed like,
especially in the seal teams,
it was like,
oh,
that's never,
that will,
that will never happen.
It'll never happen.
And sure enough,
I mean,
there,
in that book,
in our,
in our first book,
we happen to write about three different,
I mean,
there's 12 chapters in three of them,
concern,
friendly,
fire because you had to be more concerned about,
well,
not more concerned about you,
but you had to be at least as concerned about deconfliction and you know,
we would hang out.
We would hang,
you know,
giant aircraft
panels and once,
once my guys would take a building for a sniper,
Overwatch position,
oftentimes if there was any question about where they were,
they'd hang giant air panels right out the window,
right.
As soon as they started shooting.
And the enemy knew every word.
We wanted to make sure that the friendlies knew where we were just as bad.
So yeah,
the,
the um,
the friendly fire problems that happened.
But when I came back and I started running training,
I would induce those and,
and,
and they happen to 100% of the platoons that I put through training.
100% of them had had blue on blues,
you know,
with paint ball or with the laser tag system that we used because it's,
it's one of those things,
no one thinks it can happen to them,
you know.
The other,
the other part of that,
to be really frank here,
um,
in the,
the,
the areas where we were operating,
um,
you know,
you,
you done,
we'd send night acts out every night,
you know,
you,
we can move.
We moved every three,
four days,
new perimeter.
Um,
you'd send out listening posts as an listening posts and ambushes,
um,
after dark.
And you know,
you've got marines out there.
They don't really know where they are,
you know,
I mean,
they don't have a map.
You know,
he had two or three people in,
has a map.
Um,
and sometimes they are out where they're supposed to be,
where they are,
where they think they are.
Uh,
and sometimes,
you know,
if you get somebody who's getting a little flaky,
he'll say,
well,
we don't have to go out there and we'll,
let's,
let's just go sit in this bomb crater here.
And they had an incident before I got to the company,
uh,
where,
there was,
uh,
a fire team that was sitting in a bomb crater about 50 meters out outside the
lines,
and a guy stood up at like two in the morning and take a leak and then Renin on
the line shot him.
And,
uh,
you know,
the guy who shot him ended up being a chaplain's assistant.
I mean,
you live with that the rest of your life.
Uh,
and by the time I got to be company commander,
I,
I put something into place which was very effective.
And that is first thing I would do is I would send out my night acts when it was
still light and I would send them,
what I call it,
a day pause,
uh,
the listening post out to an outpost further away,
the ambush to a site.
I would have them walk by the site where they're,
you know,
quietly check it out and then go to a,
to a pause,
like a hundred meters away or whatever.
So,
and then when it got dark,
they both were moving into known terrain,
um,
you know,
the LP coming back toward the perimeter.
So they had a sense of security there,
the ambush,
having researched the,
you know,
the ambush and moving back into it.
And then I would mortar of their day pause.
And the first time I did that,
I had an ambulance out about click and a half away and they call and you got to
be advised,
you're dropping mortars on us.
I said,
you are not where you're supposed to be doing.
What,
what are you going to do if you,
if you hit something,
you know,
what do you know?
Where are we going to do?
We're going to really drop rounds on you.
You know,
so god,
everything real straight,
your wedding down,
drop borders on your people.
Make sure,
well,
if you're,
if I'm hitting you with a mortar,
you're not where you're supposed to be and it's going to get a lot worse if you
get hit out there.
Well,
that's that,
that'll solve that problem.
Uh,
you,
you talk about,
you know,
I walked in,
this is back of the book.
I walked every square kilometers writ of those ridges and rice fields.
I fought many of those villages.
I was wounded there.
And here is where I and my fellow combat veterans stand on one side of a great
impassable,
divide with the rest of the world on the other.
Okay.
Yeah,
because every one of us knows that if our luck had run out or if someone among
us had made one inadvertent mistake,
we could have died there.
No question.
You can be.
That's one thing about,
you know,
I've heard you talk about edis before,
I would say
25 to 30% of our casualties were iads.
Most of them were gunshot,
lot of shrapnel wounds.
Uh,
but with an IED,
there's nothing more demoralizing or booby trap is we call it the,
uh,
and the particular,
you're moving at night,
the casualties are large.
Uh,
and uh,
there's nowhere to put your anger,
you know it.
And if you're on that,
on the outside of that,
you go,
Whoa,
you know,
that easily could have been me.
You can to be 100% right and still be dead.
We had one device on a night move.
Every member of my platoon stepped over it on a,
on a narrow trail.
I was walking fourth,
fourth parade,
fourth marine in them in a column.
And the last I t we had a brand new guy.
I put them on tail end,
Charlie.
It was a company move,
Raechel leading battalion,
but it was a company move and it was a,
some branch on the trail or something and called boom.
And,
uh,
you know,
whether a 19 casualties and a ambush after that.
So you have,
for those of you that aren't in the military when you're moving at night,
especially pre night vision,
then the only way you can do it is you have to be closer to the person in front
of you.
Cause you gotta be able to see them.
And so what that doesn't and you'll be within or within beating up in sometimes
when it's really dark,
you will be able to touch the person in front of you.
So therefore,
if someone hits a booby trap or an Iud or you get ambushed,
the casualties are increased dramatically because you're just all together.
To add one thing about Ramadi on that is a,
I think when we got there,
they had 140 known IED is on the board any given time.
And uh,
there were a couple different incidents on one.
One particular that sticks in my mind was when we were putting in the 17th
street security station,
a friend of mine,
his platoon was out,
uh,
providing external security with gun trucks.
And I guess he saw his truck sat on an IED all night and they're right when they
were about to move it went off and took the front of the truck with it.
Luckily nobody was killed.
But it's uh,
it's not that you can shoot back at,
you can't really prepare for it.
Yeah.
Sometimes you got to get lucky.
We had the similar thing where we,
we will go into a combat outpost in a convoy of just,
you know,
our seals hadn't do a convoy or heading to a combat outpost.
And my point man or lead driver,
someone said,
hey,
I think there's something ahead of us in the road,
stops the vehicle.
I'm actually watched him.
He gets out looking underneath the vehicle,
the flashlight to look and see.
I'm thinking to myself,
hmm,
this doesn't seem good.
Co didn't identify anything.
We roll through.
We get to the combat outpost.
And then a couple hours later,
uh,
the dagger clearance team came through and found a triple stack,
you know,
120 millimeter mortars that would've killed everyone in that vehicle for sure.
And if not a few others.
So,
uh,
sometimes it's better to be lucky than good.
And for those of you out there,
if you think you're on an ID,
maybe not the flashlight approach,
absolutely.
Quietly walk away.
Yeah,
I had,
I do that.
It was my,
my first deployment to Iraq.
I'm standing there and my EOD guys,
we're doing a target at night.
My Eod guys find a,
uh,
a booby trap and it was in a plan or box outside perfect spot where we're at.
Assault team would stack up and there was a little plant and it was filled with
a two or three 60 millimeter mortars that were rigged from the house.
And so my EOD guy found it was just,
you plug it into the wall and it goes off.
So there was,
and there was actually a little,
a little hole cut in the curtain so the guy could actually sit there and watch.
And when we rolled up,
boom.
And so he found the wire,
he saw it,
went out the window,
fault it out there,
finds the booby trap.
And I'm standing there watching him,
uh,
you know,
disarm this booby trap and he looks over his shoulder and he says,
you might not want to stand here.
And I was like,
that's a good point.
I'll be a somewhere else.
Well,
you know,
they,
uh,
in,
in this area,
in this area of Vietnam,
um,
they could become accustomed to a lot of our operational decisions.
You know,
we liked the high ground.
We like to get a spot where you can see some of these rice patties were like a
mile wide,
you know,
and if you want a place where you can have visuals and also provide,
potential supporting weaponry for people crossing and Patty,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And so,
you know,
they,
they picked these out,
you know,
and,
uh,
um,
we had one hill,
he'll 11 in Arizona valley where,
uh,
you,
you know,
we'd send it when we'd be getting any strain features.
The thing,
you do,
what you'd send a platoon to sweep it.
You know,
when you first get up,
sweep it,
secure it,
not just for booby traps,
but you know,
for putting your,
your,
uh,
your other units in the platoon,
swept it with second platoon.
They found a mine,
uh,
Luna Mine.
Uh,
I left,
I was going to put my lines in and I,
I,
uh,
didn't want to bring my platoon up on that hill,
but with the having found the mine.
So I,
uh,
left the rest of my platoon on the bottom of OpenAir panel and my Garvey's head,
my radio operator,
he said,
do not move.
I want to see where you are.
I brought my squad leaders,
we were clearing lanes down into where we were going to put our marines.
And I heard this,
Kaboom.
And I look up behind me and someone had moved these people up to the top of the
hill.
I turned around to see a guy flying through the air with a big artillery round.
Um,
and I saw him a Garvey.
I'm running with his arm hanging by,
by a shred.
He was standing behind him.
So we had casualties on top of that hill.
Pretty,
pretty messy after a lot of other things we'd been through.
Um,
and then the next morning,
our,
uh,
81 CFO when we set up our perimeter getting mortared that afternoon,
and,
uh,
he,
he rolled over the next morning in his elbow,
went down and he reached up and it was like a piece,
a little piece of c ration cardboard.
Uh,
he peeled it covered with mud,
like,
you know,
like plastic surgery.
So nothing lifted it up.
And there was a one seven,
five artillery round with a pressure release detonator on it that he had slept
all night.
Uh,
if he had just rolled over with a bit,
I think they found 15 would be traps on that,
on that one hill eventually.
Uh,
so
what a nightmare.
Um,
and I guess what would a good job on him on?
I'll get a sound night's sleep now.
I think he's probably woke up in the middle of night on that one a few times.
Thinking about how lucky,
lucky,
um,
here,
here's your tart and you talk a little bit about the overall kind of the
overall,
I guess the overall occurrences that were going on were beyond what's just
sitting right in front of you.
So here we go.
But something else was going on at stem from the reality that on any given day,
three different wars were being fought in the basin.
The first war involved conventional combat against North Vietnamese army
regulars and main force Viet Cong soldiers.
The second war was the daily challenge of an insurgency dominated by a longterm
war of attrition aimed at driving American public opinion and troop morale
against our own involvement in Vietnam at the beginning of what became known as
the American war communist leader.
Ho Ci Minh famously predicted,
for every one of you we kill,
you will kill 10 of us.
But in the end it is,
you will,
who will grow tired.
The third war focused was a focused and precise form of domestic terrorism.
At this point in our history,
America's top leadership had yet to fully grasp the power and impact of a type
of terrorism that went well beyond the traditional notions of military
insurgency.
Nor did the south Vietnamese government ever find a way to completely counter
it.
It was,
uh,
sorry,
largely invisible war of terror and subduction was taking place daily among the
rural populace,
designed to discredit the south Vietnamese government and to drive a murderous
wedge between the people and the government.
And you go on to talk about,
uh,
Bernard Fall and his book,
you know,
he's a French author who wrote a bunch of books,
uh,
spent time there,
wrote a book called Helen,
a very small place,
and he warned the Dick Van,
am I saying that right?
They Been Dick Vaughn,
Dick Vaughn,
um,
or moral intervention cadres.
The,
these were groups.
And what they were doing was the violent act for psychological rather than
military reasons,
which is the source of the success.
And the Viet Minh and the Dick Vaughn will simply go on murdering village
chiefs,
youth leaders,
teachers,
and anti-malarial teams.
Thus isolating the Saigon government from the countryside,
and you describe one of these situations.
There was no warning from around that unseen.
Bend the air.
Suddenly belched interrupted quick explosions piercing our ears and
reverberating like an unseen blast of wind.
My adrenaline surged.
I counted three quick bursts of rifle fire,
and then a wimp of three grenades.
The entire platoon became animated tents picking up the pace to a jog.
As we strode toward the noise within a few heartbeats,
a young Vietnamese wild eyed and gasping for breath collided on the trail with
the point man of the platoon.
Instinctively,
the marine tackle the young man and held them on the ground.
We did not know it yet,
but there had been two others.
After its attack,
the assassination squad at split apart,
we would not capture the other two more regrettably,
we would not be able to kill them.
The district chiefs meeting had not lasted very long.
We were the first marines to reach the hooch.
I quickly deployed my platoon in defensive positions around it.
In case there was a second attack.
Then I stepped inside the shadowed blood soaked room.
My Platoon Corman and my radio operator came with me.
Within minutes,
our company's chief Korman stepped inside,
having jogged down from the command post on Henderson Hill.
Their unit one medical bags would soon be empty of battle dressing and turn
acquit tourniquets.
Together we began the ugly business of triage separating the dead from the near
dead and the near dead from those who might be medically saved inside the hooch.
My hands armed arms trousers and boots at quickly become covered with blood.
We pulled the debt outside,
lining them up in the field as if they were already under markers in a cemetery.
Then covered them up so that the feasting flies might find some other place to
linger.
We had a problem with flies on the battlefield.
They buzzed everywhere into our food and onto our open sores.
On an earlier morning,
I had counted more than a dozen floating inside my canteen cup.
As I heated a mix of water and see ration hot chocolate.
Foolishly,
I had bitten into them thinking they were chunks of chocolate.
We carried out the wounded on the dirt floor of the coach.
We had found them wriggling and turning like worms among each other as they had
sought to escape the ankle.
Deep Syrup of blood and innards.
I noticed the district chiefs,
young deputy deputy who stood out from the others due to his fancy clothes,
blown backward into a family alter by the blast.
He was frozen in depth with one arm raised in the air as if you were trying to
catch their grenade that had killed him.
That hand was gone.
Nothing but the top of a forearm remained it's white tendon sticking out
randomly like on spliced electrical wires.
I had approached an old woman who was leaning back against a mud wall with a
stunned look on her face.
Her jaw had dropped and her eyes stared unbelievably at nothing.
I thought she was merely in shock.
I pulled her arm and immediately recognize the lack of muscular response of the
dead.
I took a closer look and saw that she had taken a square nickel sized piece of
shrapnel.
In the middle for forehead just above rise.
Okay.
And so on.
As I waited in the mock,
it did not get any better.
This was the war we were losing perfectly.
Summarizing Bernard falls observation on this morning,
the Vietcong were not asking for anyone support.
They were asserting their control
for all of the bombs.
We dropped many of them so randomly that they killed people,
that they killed the very people we were trying to help.
And for all the,
for all of us enemy soldiers,
we killed our leaders,
did not understand the cold focused violence perpetrated by the other side.
They had deliberately killed a room full of their own people,
a violent act for psychological rather than military reasons as a warning to
everyone in the basin that it was a crime punishable by death to even attend a
political meeting hosted by the other side.
True.
Let me,
let me,
uh,
let me see if I can,
I can go back to the three points that,
that you wrote about and just elaborate a little bit.
There were three wars in any given.
I
talked a little bit about it earlier on the street,
a conventional side,
unit against unit.
There's,
there's no question.
We,
we defeated those forces.
Um,
finally,
and you know,
people during the war,
we're talking about the body count,
the body count,
the inflated body count,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
in 1995,
Hanoi admitted they lost 1.4 million soldiers dead,
1.4 million soldiers dead.
Uh,
we lost 58,000.
The South Vietnamese W I w I really want to say something about,
because I think they are,
have been disrespected by history.
They lost about 250,000 debt.
Um,
and so we did our job.
That was our main job.
The second war.
You're talking about the guerrilla war.
I think we did well,
but we could have done better.
One of the things that Bernard Fall,
uh,
talked about was how our,
you know,
are supporting arms are we used,
we used,
um,
we heavily use artillery mortars and these sort of things.
And in the villages it seemed kind of random.
Uh,
and the communists were very focused,
you know,
not,
not on the battlefield,
but how they use stuff outside the battlefield.
They're very focused on who they were,
who they were after a,
in addition to like showing that they could,
they could meet up with us.
But even on,
even on that war,
I mean,
we adapted and I,
and that area that I operated in,
um,
you know,
by the time I'd been there four or five months,
I understood the tempo of that place.
I understood where they were.
They were,
were,
they had been,
I could anticipate them.
Uh,
and we did some,
I think some really great things.
By the time I got to be a company commander out there in terms of knocking,
knocking them off balance,
keeping the morale of our troops up,
you know,
showing them that we,
we really,
we could go where they were and we could figure out what they were going to do.
Um,
the third was the key.
And I will say,
I want to say a couple of things about that.
First,
you know,
the,
the South Vietnamese,
the motivation of the South Vietnamese I think has been misunderstood.
And I didn't understand this one.
I was in Vietnam.
I understood this a lot better when I got back from Vietnam.
I started working with the Vietnamese community here after 1975 helping them
understand the political system that they were moving into.
You know,
they came,
they came here,
they were very,
they were organized into community groups.
They,
they knew that,
you know,
they
were going to put the future into their kids.
You know,
from day one it was get a job,
you know,
uh,
but meeting with them,
get a job,
get your kids in school,
the next generation is going to succeed.
Um,
but also they were able to explain in a way that I never got out there where I
was about what it was they were trying to do and how,
you know,
you,
if you could do the communist,
uh,
approach to this was very stolen us.
How's your man?
Was,
he may,
he may have been a nationalist,
but he studied the common term in,
in Moscow for like seven years.
Uh,
he knew the tactics that we're going to be used to eliminate the opposition of
Vietnamese opposition and to also put the markers down.
Um,
the,
the South Vietnamese,
uh,
never found a way to totally respond to this.
And they were constantly getting their leaders.
They had a lot of corruption.
The culture as a mandarin culture.
There's a lot of corruption in the,
in the,
in the cold culture writ large when you get a,
you know,
people in positions of power.
Three big temptation and demand root system.
Um,
but they were saying,
um,
despite what I mentioned earlier about the assassination programs that were not
fully understood and in our country,
they were saying the people who were opposed to the war were saying the south
Vietnamese were so corrupt,
they won't go out there.
You know,
we have a district chief and Dunay,
he lives in his villa.
He has a great life.
He won't go out to the annual basis.
Um,
and so our company commander,
who part of his first store,
he had done as a,
you know,
pacification officer working with them,
said,
we're going to get them out here,
we're going to protect him.
And they found out about that and as,
as I wrote in the book,
I mean,
they,
they killed 17 of their own people in one little room and the,
the district chief and his aide,
you know,
just to send the signal,
that signal was well understood,
you know,
by the people in,
in these areas.
And what we were doing was not as well understood even by ourselves.
One of the,
you know,
the most interesting moments for me was when I had a,
uh,
I was toward the end of my tour,
I had a marine who was getting court martialed and tonight for hitting an Nco,
uh,
you would not in my company anymore.
Uh,
but he said,
I'm getting a court martial.
I,
you know,
I called on his land light on the regimental three shop,
cause I'm getting court martialed and I don't,
uh,
you don't have a lawyer I can talk to,
can you come in and help me out to an hour?
And I got permission to go into Danang.
Like,
so I went to the three math headquarters.
They had this great dining hall,
you know,
and that you had to try to get to.
So I went over to the three math,
had dinner,
and I went into a bar and there's this woman,
it's Vietnamese woman who was working behind the bar and she had a black diamond
sewn into her Alizai.
Um,
and uh,
so she was,
you know,
she saw me and all droopy,
mustache.
My boots are blind.
Uh,
definitely my hair's a little longer.
I definitely don't belong in three math headquarters.
She said,
you are,
uh,
you're from out there.
I said,
yeah,
it's just,
where are you?
And I signed it and won.
She says,
I'm from dialogue,
which is the,
was the major town at the corner,
eastern corner of the Arizona Bank.
And,
uh,
she said,
you're doing so much good.
You know,
I went,
really?
And she said,
she said,
you know why I wear this?
She said they killed my entire family.
She said in dialogue or her father was a police officer.
They came in at night,
they killed everybody.
She was shot,
but you know,
everybody but her was killed.
Her husband was an arb and he was just,
had just been killed.
And she said,
you know,
you,
we,
you know,
we can go places now.
We couldn't go three years ago.
You know,
you are,
you are winning.
And you know,
it's the first time anybody had ever,
ever said that to me,
you know,
and another comment needs to be made.
And that is that the South Vietnamese leadership,
uh,
the military leadership,
my age,
there were a lot of really fine leaders in there.
And even,
even David Hackworth,
you know,
who said,
uh,
you know,
the north Vietnamese slash going to be flying over Saigon by 1975 also said
emphatically to me when I was interviewing him.
If you'd gotten these people into position,
they would have,
I'm not gonna say they would have one,
but they would've survived.
South Vietnam would have survived like South Korea.
West Germany was about 40 eventual better solution.
So they have been,
I think,
uh,
you know,
libeled in,
in history,
in terms of the competence of,
of a lot of their,
they're really good leaders and people and soldiers and marines.
And that,
that's,
and that's from your perspective where you doing joint patrols with them?
Well,
here's the interesting thing.
Um,
one of the reasons that,
uh,
the,
the combat temple went up in early 69,
uh,
was that Nixon had been elected president.
The communists were very smart at keying in their military operations to our
politics.
64 golf,
a tonka at 68 knocked a president out at 68,
72.
The Easter offensive,
which you're criminal redrew,
was that his name was,
was talking about so eloquently in one of your shows.
And they wanted Nixon.
Nixon was going to meet president too,
on,
in Guam in June of,
of,
uh,
1969.
And they wanted the Americans to say they're getting out of there.
I don't know that I can't,
I couldn't sit there when I was over there going,
yeah,
this is what's happening.
But so late April,
all of May,
Hamburger Hill and 90th regimen,
every,
you know,
the place lit up for her and 50 people dying.
Um,
but Nixon announced Vietnamization it's been mocked,
it should not have been mocked.
Um,
in the Arizona Valley.
We hadn't seen South Vietnamese out in Arizona Valley.
And then I was out there as a company,
commanded,
brought a ranger unit out and it Kinda got waxed and we actually moved down to
their PR,
you know,
to their,
their perimeter and they were jumping on helicopters to get out.
Um,
and then they send a unit,
um,
all the 51st Arvin regimen out there.
And these guys were good.
I mean,
I would,
I would have operated with them any day.
Um,
and I've got,
you know,
many,
many friends who were Arbonne in Vietnam who will talk to you about what
happened when the Watergate Congress took over,
you know,
in the Nixon resigned.
And then,
you know,
the s antiwar Congress came in and one of the first substantive votes they took
was to cut off all supplemental appropriations to the South Vietnamese army.
There was,
that was,
there was no reason for that.
Well are our forces weren't even on the ground over there.
And at the same time the north Vietnamese refurbished and they attacked them
when they were repositioning.
They had to reposition.
I have a really great friend,
you know,
um,
who,
uh,
when I was listening to your show that we're talking about the American,
who had spent nine years as a prisoner of war,
uh,
[inaudible],
who's here now,
uh,
spent 12 years on a battlefield,
was a regimental commander at age 28,
recipient of their,
uh,
metal of honor in 13 and a half years,
locked up five years on a conex box.
Um,
he was down to two artillery rounds per tube per day when he was trying to
reposition his forces when this thing hit.
So,
um,
it was a very complicated war.
I'm not trying to like,
you know,
Re uh,
reimagine what was happening.
But I had always thought that the,
the end result would probably be kind of like what you see in Iraq,
just sort of a slow down and sort things out rather than what happened.
Right.
Okay.
Going back to the book while my mother slept so fitfully and so fifthly,
dreamed I was hit by two enemy grenades while clearing a series of well
camouflaged bunkers.
Bunkers were built inside of bamboo thicket at the edge of a murky stream bed.
The first grenade peppered me lightly on the face and shoulders.
The second detonated behind me just after I shot the man who threw it in a
second soldier who was inside the same bunker.
I was hitting the head back,
arm and leg,
the grenades concussion lifted me into the air and threw me down a hill into the
stream.
I still carry shrapnel at the base of my skull and in one kidney from the blast.
But the square quarter sized piece that scored the inside of my left knee joint
and lodged against the bone of my lower leg would eventually change the
direction of my life.
Having for months repeatedly seen far worse among of my marines.
How did not pay a great deal of attention to my wounds?
Medivaced into Al Holla,
Eh,
I was treated for several days at the battalion aid station.
Some of the shrapnel in the back in my head,
back and arm was removed and some was left to work its way out.
Naturally as my skin healed over time,
the scars pushing shrapnel out onto the surface.
I returned to the Bush as soon as possible,
but the leg wound went deep into the joint and had not completely healed in the
mock of the rice paddies and the filth of the basin villas.
It soon became infected.
I did not know it at the time,
but the infection was moving into the bone causing permanent septic damage.
And then you go to,
uh,
in August,
your company executive officer,
he let you know that there's a bill.
It opened up for Force Service Regiment on Okinawa.
And for those people that don't know what it is,
this is like a plush billet and here you go.
If I accepted the assignment for me,
the Vietnam war would be over within weeks and an assignment on the quaint and
gorgeous island of Okinawa would give me several months to decompress from
battlefield combat before I returned home.
Okay.
Life's gambles are sometimes settled in mere moments,
weighed against years of previous thought and decades on the other side where
one might reflect on the wisdom involved in a sudden decision.
I listened to the executive officer and fought inside myself pressing the radio
handset against my face as I leaned against an old grave in the middle of a
desolate village.
Those few seconds became,
as they liked to say in the marine corps,
a teachable moment.
But I could not say yes.
After all the years of preparation and months of hardship that I had endured
with one infantry battalion in this small but violent section of a seemingly
never ending more,
I could not simply walk away.
Bonds formed on the battlefield are often is unbreakable as the strongest family
ties in a word.
I felt obligated like my father service to country defined myself.
Respect more to the point I loved leading infantry marines.
Okay.
With a Gritty Alon,
they faced the greatest dangerous.
They took the greatest risk.
They absorbed the highest casualties.
They had the fewest creature comforts,
but they also stood face to face and toe to toe with the enemy every day.
And they answered in their honor to no one.
Yeah.
Taking a deep breath.
I finally said No.
Then stayed in the Bush in September.
I was given command of dying
Delta.
No complaints.
No,
it's,
um,
during that time,
I had served under four battalion commanders and three regimental commanders.
Um,
and as you know,
I mean it was,
I'd say majority of the people who,
who go through this experience,
no.
Uh,
there are,
there are a few bonds in your life tighter than the people,
um,
that you have served with under extraordinary circumstances.
I once wrote in one article,
I don't say I would trust my life to these people cause I already have.
Uh,
and I knew,
I knew what I was doing.
You know,
I knew the terrain.
I felt like I belonged there.
There was a,
there's a scene in fields of fire where snake was a squad leader.
Uh,
the good,
you're ready to go on an operation.
And he goes and sits on a bunker,
uh,
looking out across the patties at the,
at the fog pouring down the mountains.
And so,
you know,
yeah.
As this,
this is where I belong,
you know.
And,
um,
my third regimental commander who,
uh,
was a real piece of work and with Noble Beck,
pulled me in.
He,
he found out I had two purple hearts as an officer in the bush and which was
against the division order.
And as he,
as he said,
um,
when I left Vietnam,
he said this guy came in with tears as big as horse turds in his eyes.
And you know,
the,
the greatest job I've ever had.
It's been a rifle company commander,
just enough independence to really be innovative but still totally connected
with your people.
And I've been very privileged,
um,
in,
in my life to be able to maintain a contact,
not only with the people that I have,
many of the people that I served with,
but also with the operating military.
Uh,
and I,
I learned when I,
uh,
when I was in law school,
I,
you know,
that's where I finally ended up,
um,
cause I to figure out I need to screw my brain on and figure out the rest of my
life.
Um,
I found out that I could make money by writing.
It was like the pure formula here.
You know,
I could actually get people to pay me to indulge my curiosities.
And so I was able,
I was able,
among other things too,
you know,
to be with the military,
our military and a lot of different places.
I was in Beirut in 1983,
uh,
when I covered it for PBS.
Um,
and actually I left right before the building blew up.
I stop every year,
October 23rd.
And think about that.
That was a good battalion,
first battalion,
eighth marines,
you know,
you've been around this long enough,
you can smell a good,
good unit and you can tell a bad unit.
And they were a good unit.
They were well led.
Um,
I,
uh,
was able to be in Afghanistan,
you know,
as a,
as an embed over there,
uh,
spent,
been able to spend time working on veteran's issues,
spent five years in the Pentagon.
Uh,
so,
uh,
you can,
you can take this sort of,
you know,
affiliation and Camaraderie and,
and have it still helped in other things you do in your life.
So that was,
that was it right when,
uh,
when the colonel brought you in and he just said,
hey,
look,
I don't care.
You're going home.
You're,
you're out.
you're not going to stay here anymore.
And there was no,
I always get your butts about that one.
No,
there was not,
um,
you know,
as soon as he found out I had two purple hearts.
Um,
and I,
I was on the regimental in the regimen or three shop for my last two months and
then came home and then started,
you know,
my,
uh,
situation with the joint in my leg started
acting up after I got home.
And by the way,
you,
you wrote this whole book and you spent,
I think it was a half or maybe a quarter or a paragraph or maybe three sentences
talking about you attacking enemy bunkers,
throwing grenades in,
getting wounded,
fighting on,
um,
if that's,
that's the,
that's that's what you received,
the navy cross four.
And,
um,
well I just wanted to point out that that's a,
that takes humble to a new level for you to write this book and give yourself a,
a sentence or two.
When I,
when I decided to write fields of fire,
um,
I was,
I was in law school.
Um,
there was,
uh,
it was a very important concept that stuck in my mind and it's still there.
And that is that the people who went over and interrupted their lives,
a lot of them just spent one,
one tour in the Marine Corps and what home have never been fully appreciate.
I've never been fully understood,
you know,
and what they did,
getting that down,
you know,
that the environment in which they served.
And you know,
that there's a,
when we talk about courage,
there's physical courage,
which is maybe shooting somebody in a walker.
There's moral courage,
which is standing up for what you believe in and having the courage to say it to
those above you.
And sometimes you have to say it to those who are,
who are below you,
you know,
no,
you got to do this.
That's all there is to it.
And then there's what I like to call daily courage,
you know,
and daily courage is taking a hand.
God dealt you and doing something with it.
You know,
uh,
like Tom Martin,
who,
uh,
was one of my squad leaders,
it was a,
he's now passed away.
Um,
he was an interesting,
uh,
W W W was an intersting ear for me in the bush.
He had been in Vandy.
Vanderbilt University was in favor of the war.
It wasn't a debate on the war.
And this guy who supposedly is going to Canada to turn around and said,
if you think this is such a great war,
why don't you just go serve in it?
He enlisted.
It's even very,
very smart knowing guy could,
you know,
put things would get down.
You come and talk,
talk to me about different stuff.
Then he got shot and he used to keep out and everybody had the Zippo lighter,
you know,
uh,
with your slogan on it and his,
his,
uh,
slogan was,
life is not in drawing a good hand,
but learning to play a poor hand.
Well,
uh,
and that takes daily courage,
you know,
and we had an,
our in our platoon,
uh,
had to triple amputees.
One,
one died,
uh,
before they got him out of Vietnam.
Uh,
but Dale Wilson was,
the other one was a silver star recipient.
One of the most positive people I've ever met.
Uh,
if you,
if you met him,
you wouldn't,
you would know the hit had lost an arm,
but you wouldn't,
you know,
and he'd be leaning on a cane.
You wouldn't be able to tell he lost one leg up by the thigh or above the thigh
and the other one tumbling.
He
takes Dale Wilson 15 minutes to get out of bed.
That's daily courage and he never,
never complaints.
He'll,
you know,
he'll say,
well,
I was going to be an NFL.
What else?
What else should I be doing here?
Magma Garby arm blown off my below the shoulder,
uh,
went out and got a tattoo,
says cut on dotted line.
When I ran for the Senate,
when I decide to run for the Senate,
nine months to the day before the election,
it was zero money,
zero campaign staff.
I just said,
I'm going to do this.
First guy called was Hma Garvey.
He was the night manager.
Tootsies orchid lounge in Nashville,
Tennessee.
I said,
man,
I need somebody I can trust,
you know,
24 hours a day.
You gotta be my driver.
He says,
I got one arm,
I said,
I don't care.
You're my driver.
Uh,
he quit his job and moved into our basement for a year.
And,
uh,
you know,
I couldn't,
I couldn't have done it without,
I mean,
great,
great friend of Sun gyms too,
by the way.
So that's,
that's daily courage,
you know,
and that's,
that's really when you look at the ramifications of that place and having people
understand,
you know,
what,
how this was in many ways positive for our country to,
uh,
that's my goal.
So you sir,
you're in law school and you know,
you've,
you've mentioned this a couple times so far,
but at some point you decide,
okay,
um,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna start writing.
Why did you decide to write a novel instead of write a book of your own
experiences?
And I mean,
I know,
and I'm going to get into it a little bit.
I mean,
clearly there's a major amount of crossover,
but is there a specific reason
why you said,
you know what,
I'm gonna write a novel instead of a,
uh,
a memoir.
Well,
there's two things.
I started writing my last year in the Marine Corps,
it was put on the secretary of the navy.
Stefan was on those medical hold.
And I,
you know,
as,
as we discussed earlier,
as an avid reader,
I loved,
I loved to write,
I was writing from my job.
I wrote three,
um,
uh,
magazine articles in that year.
One of them was very controversial.
It was about the,
uh,
roles and missions of the Marine Corps,
how they were on paper,
an amphibious force,
and they were doing all these other things and it,
did it make a difference in my bottom line?
Would you better believe it makes a difference?
Uh,
there's not one marine general on any of these j staffs anywhere except that,
you know,
if,
if the navy gives him one in the Marine Corps wasn't even represented when they
decided that that was their mission.
It was the chief of naval operations and I was 25 years old and I got in big
trouble.
You think I got in big trouble and some of these other things I've written,
you know,
the chief of staff of the Marine Corps was calling me into talking to me and the
commandant ordered a counter article to be written,
uh,
about what I had said because they,
they were being accused in the jcs of,
you know,
this,
wanting to start some sort of a campaign,
you know.
Um,
so I had learned the power of the written word and then I wrote my first year in
law school I,
I sort of look in and I had started looking at Micronesia and what's going to
happen after the Vietnam War,
what should the United States basing system look like in the,
in the Pacific.
And I was reading a lot of World War II stuff and you know,
Ronald in the desert was,
you know,
fighting from what he called the interior position.
You know,
logistically shortening of logistic lines,
being able to hit the Brits when they were after him and hit the Americans when
they were after him.
And I said,
we need to develop an interior position in,
in Pacific Asia.
And that's Guam.
Tinian I got really kind of into this,
I wrote my first book actually about that and when I worked,
uh,
for the governor of Guam doing a study.
So then I'm saying,
I'm listening to the stuff that people were saying about those who served.
I think I met three people in three years in Georgetown law school who had been
in combat in Vietnam,
1800 people,
student body,
same age group.
Something was wrong.
And I actually was sitting in constitutional law class when they were debating
the war powers act.
And it got to be very vicious on,
uh,
you know,
the people who served there.
I want to stuff they'd never said to my face,
they're saying to each other and this class and go,
Holy Shit.
That's what they really believe.
And I started writing the last chapter,
fields of fire are sitting in constitutional law class.
And then as I wrote it,
you know,
the first time I wrote this book,
seven times cover to cover and an engineering degree,
you know,
and,
um,
you know,
I never went to a creative writing class.
I started reading the people I thought were the greats,
um,
in a different way,
not for enjoyment,
but for structure and these sorts of things.
Hemingway,
Steinbeck,
Faulkner,
uh,
Graham Greene,
the British,
the Irish poets,
et Cetera.
Um,
so the first time through it was sort of like,
just,
you know,
it was a very good catharsis.
And then I got to the point where I said,
no,
I've got a piece of literature here.
Uh,
every one of these characters is a little bit different and it is an escalating
moral drama,
uh,
in terms of how they are reacting to operating in this particular area.
Uh,
and so
the,
the power,
the literary power of the novel was,
was more important than me telling.
Uh,
I was there kind of story,
had a universality to it and a jeopardy,
uh,
who came in to help me on us.
Um,
who had woke,
discovered Leon Uris was editor and chief of Putin up at one time.
Uh,
uh,
just really encouraged me to stay with it.
And I,
you know,
I very lucky that I did because I had the book survived,
12 rejections and everything else and us
well out there.
No.
So,
uh,
and,
and honestly,
I kind of answered that question for myself and I think when people read it,
they'll figure out why you did it.
Cause it does,
it has this power to it that you couldn't have done.
I'm just writing your own story.
Even though your own story is,
is very similar and has probably parts that are just even more impactful.
But the way that this ties together,
and this is,
this is like the iconic novel and I will say about Vietnam War,
but really like you could put this over just war and you've got these characters
in it.
You know,
you already talked about one of them.
You got snake who's like the street smart kind of bad ass marine.
You got Lieutenant Robert E.
Lee Hodges,
who's,
who's the lieutenant,
he got the senator who's this Harvard kid that thought he going to play the
French horn and the marine corps band and he ends up in the basin.
Uh,
uh,
you got cat man who's the,
the Mexican point man.
You got the Terp,
the interpreters,
we called him Dan.
You got cannonball flaky bag or rabbit,
uh,
Gilliland baby cakes,
sergeant Austins.
And in all of these characters in the end,
you know,
as I read this,
it was just,
you know,
I probably read this 10 years ago or something,
maybe 15 years ago and when I read it again,
I mean it's just infinitely,
I mean,
just because I'm older and I understand things more,
I guess my hope,
but just the way that each one of these characters and,
and here's something that I realized I was,
I was reading this book.
First of all,
we know these characters,
like these characters,
they exist in real life.
They exist in combat.
They enlisted,
they exist in the seal teams.
They exist in the Marine Corps.
They exist in the army.
I met all of these characters,
they're all out there and they're all out there.
I work with businesses now they're in those businesses as well.
They're in there.
These are human beings.
And,
and that's incredible.
And then you put them in this,
you know,
look at them.
I'm interested always in learning about human nature.
But you put this in,
in this environment that is what you've talked about and this environment is to,
is gonna reveal human nature in incredible ways and you just capture so much of
it.
And
I mean,
I want to take a look at when,
when,
uh,
Hodges kind of arrives in Vietnam and he sits down with major auto.
So here we go.
This is the fields of fire.
Going back to the book,
Major Auto,
the battalion executive officer sat behind his field desk and examined Hodges
record book.
He was young for a major in his early thirties.
He seemed pleasant enough,
the Hodges,
who would expect it,
a hatchet faced revealing warrior after hearing of the majors background Ottawa
had been a company commander during his first tour and was highly decorated.
His right forearm was gashed with a six inch purple trough left by a bone
shattering machine gun bullet.
And yet he had the inquisitive,
sensitive demeanor of a brooding scholar.
He smiled casually to Hodges.
So do you think you're ready?
Hodges stood at a loose parade rest in the musty,
heated the tent.
He was scheduled to attend three more days of regimental indoctrination school,
but he had not found it helpful and he had learned to hate the dust.
Filled boredom of Anwar.
Yes sir.
I'm ready.
Thanks so good.
They need you out there.
Lost another lieutenant last night.
The major watched him closely.
Yes sir.
I heard.
Yeah.
Good old dying Delta.
You'd like to call themselves deadly.
Delta auto chuckled.
Okay.
He had a beat and tone in his voice as if he had seen the ritual so many times
it had lost its meaning,
meaning deadly dying.
Delta Hodges watched him dripping with sweat and the dark heat outside of jeep
rumbled past leaving a wave of red dirt that seeped underneath the tent flap,
like a creeping frog in the distance and artillery battery and an artillery
battery fire to mission towards the Arizona territory.
The major swiped at a fly then lit a cigarette as an afterthought.
He offered one to Hodges.
No,
thank you,
sir.
Major auto side.
You'll learn he dragged deeply on the cigarette,
frankly studying Hodges.
Yeah,
Diane Delta.
You're not ready,
lieutenant.
The only reason I'm telling you is I don't want you to panic when you get out
there and find out nothing in your entire Goddamn life will have prepared you
for the bush.
Not a damn thing.
Yes sir.
Do you know what I mean?
No Sir.
Jesus Christ,
the major dragged again on his cigarette.
Debbie Delta.
Yeah.
They really caught the shit last night.
I watched it.
It was almost embarrassing to admit he still felt uncomfortable about the irony
of sitting on a bunker and watching someone else's war.
Otto,
lean forward,
absently rubbing the purple Gash on his forearm.
Well.
What kind of person do you think goes through that Shit Day in and day out,
lieutenant,
because that's what it shit and that's the way you take it every stinking day.
Some something piddly ass or something heavy.
This isn't world war two where we can pull you out to Australia and parade after
a month of fighting.
Nope,
and it isn't 1965 when we first came into Vietnam,
we would send a company out on a two day operation,
then bring the men back for hot chow and liberty.
Yeah,
that's right.
Liberty lieutenant in Denang.
Then we started week long operations than it was a month now.
Well,
we just leave them out there all the time.
It's more convenient.
The major offered Hodges a small challenging smile.
They go wild lieutenant and there's nothing you can do about it.
You'll go wild too.
Wild as hell.
You spend a month in the bush and you're not a marine anymore.
Hell,
you're not even a goddamn person.
There's no tents,
no barbed wire,
no hot food,
no jeeps are trucks,
no clean clothes,
nothing.
You're an animal.
It gets so that it's natural to squat.
When you take a shit,
you get ringworm and hookworm and gooky sores.
You roll around in your own filth.
You forget how bad you smell dead.
People guts in the God damn dirt,
miserable civilian.
It all gets sort of boring.
You cry when your friends are killed,
but a new friend comes on a helicopter a few days later and the dead friend
becomes enshrined a martyr to friendship.
You teach the new friend about him and you all remember him.
It's very romantic.
It doesn't sound very romantic.
That's after a month or two.
But lieutenant,
when you do it for six or nine or even longer by Christ,
you'll never shake it.
The Bush gets in your blood and you hate anyone who hasn't fermented in his own
stench for months or students side a dirt hole all night waiting to kill a man
who's trying to kill him first.
Major auto scrutinized Hodges.
Oh yeah,
I've done a lot of thinking about it.
That's something a grunt isn't supposed to do.
He chuckled again,
a sort of dry bark,
but what else can a man do?
And on.
Whoah.
Oh,
and it becomes an oasis.
You like an Hola lieutenant.
I hate it.
You'll like it when you get back from the bush.
I guarantee.
So what kind of person can take it for months on end?
Hodges felt uneasy.
He'd expected the major to wave the flag and talk about he will Gima and then
send him a board.
The resupply helicopter with fire in his heart.
Someone who is very dedicated sir.
Either that or someone who's very crazy.
Well there you are.
That's in a nutshell.
You just hit the nail on the God damn head.
It's been a long time
that uh,
I mean
it's,
it's the icon is the iconic conversation between the new lieutenant and the
executive officer.
And you,
you just nailed it.
I guess I'm looking at a route that when I was 28
no,
I look,
I,
I wanted there,
there are a couple of things here.
When I started,
I said,
I am not going to write this book unless the third guy down in the third fire
team says,
this is true.
This is real.
I mean,
you know,
true,
real,
however you want to put it.
This is real.
Um,
and that was my guidepost in terms of all of the,
the combat sequences and,
and,
and this,
this sort of thing is you don't want to go through this and have it be dear
author.
I love you signed author or the way I wish it had been.
Uh,
or,
you know,
the way I would like to present it.
I remember when the,
when the book came out,
there was a,
a marine three star general who had been very helpful when I was trying to help
one on one of my former Marines who,
uh,
had had been out in this area.
And I sent him a copy of the,
the proofs and he summoned me working on the hill.
He summoned me to his quarters and eighth and I,
and he said,
this could be a primmer on marine corps tactics,
but these were not my marines.
He was a colonel.
William was over there.
And I said,
sir,
I don't know what to tell you because that's as honest as I can be.
Um,
and they were my marines and I don't have to try to make it,
he would Jima to,
to give respect to the,
to the people who were there.
But I'll tell you what,
I walked out of that,
uh,
meeting with him thinking,
Oh my God,
you know,
this is going to be really bad if,
the,
the Marine Corps turns on me for writing a book about Marines.
And then there was another two star,
uh,
General Schultz,
who had been a battalion commander and been on Taylor common.
He was with Third Marine Division,
but he'd been on Taylor common down here.
He,
he read the book and he called me.
He read it on a c one 30 from Andrews to Pendleton.
He called me.
He said,
this is the book.
This is the book.
I said,
will you send me a letter sir?
And I said,
he sent me a letter.
And,
uh,
so when I had this little,
you know,
uh,
command visit to General Wilson who was a common dot when the,
when the book came out and going,
boy,
I'm not,
I'm really nervous about the General Wilson was a hard ass,
you know,
and up.
So I got in to see General Wilson am I give him a give him a copy of the book
and I said,
and this is what general Schultes thinks about it.
And over time,
you know,
it's been mandatory reading and the commandant's reading list for decades.
And I can't tell you how many letters I've gotten from re particularly staffing
CEO's.
You know,
I'm here when I was in Beirut and you know,
as a,
as a journalist air at 83,
there was a,
there was one,
a gunnery sergeant who came and he told me,
I have read your book 11 times.
It is a text on,
you know,
on leadership if you really read it.
And at the same time,
the,
the important thing also is if you're,
if you're going to write a novel that lasts,
you want that universality.
As you say.
This doesn't just,
Vietnam has just isn't my experience.
Um,
and so it really is a very carefully drawn moral drama.
and you know,
some of these passages we're going to have it heard him in years.
And I still remember because I had written some of these 25 times,
you know,
the,
the one you started off with,
I knew the words,
you know,
I knew the words that we're going to come out of your mouth.
Uh,
so that is,
you know,
that was my intention with the book.
And,
um,
you know,
what can I say?
It's still out there and you know,
it's as honest as I can be.
And I know,
as you know,
there are a lot of rough spots in this book,
but I don't have to,
I don't have to put it any differently.
The other one other thing I will say is the dialogue,
it maybe from having benefited from living in so many different places and what
dialect is,
you know,
carefully accurate in like seven or eight different American dialects and the
way they say words in there.
Oh
yeah,
for sure.
No,
you,
you nailed that.
It's very clear.
Um,
that yet you know these people,
you know that then that you were able to capture it.
You also did a great job obviously of capturing some of the just straight combat
and I'm going to go here.
Just one little situation.
Suddenly there were loud explosions across the river.
The northern compound literally erupted.
Recoilless rifles flashed and boomed again and again.
They're explosions raising clouds of dirt inside the compound machine,
guns and small arms hammered at the marines.
The two platoon perimeter fought back red and green tracers interlaced careening
into the black air,
making weaving patterns in the night.
The artillery battery on the bridge compound reacted.
It turns its guns north and lob dozens of projectiles across the river seeking
to silence the attack.
New Bright flashes,
Hayes's of dust grouped around the northern compound.
Then a moment of anticipatory lull.
Goodrich knew what was about to happen.
He wished he could tell them in the bridge compound.
He wished he could dig a hole in the dirt and come back out in California.
Watch out.
He groaned inwardly too.
Afraid to cry.
Oh Shit.
Here it comes right now,
an avalanche and mortar rounds time from a dozen tubes to land together on the
southern compound.
Then just above the stranded team,
the deep pops of heavy machine gun Goodrich.
Listen to himself whimper.
He could not stifle it.
It seemed to him a scream that would give them all away,
but he finally realized it was no more than a scratchy whispering wine.
The bridge compounds defenders were caught unaware having to feel like
spectators in the northern compounds.
Furious defense bodies went flat inside their bunker seeking cover from the
mortar barrage as they did.
Streams of sappers poured through the outer wire,
sliding pipes of Bangalore torpedoes to clear pathways through the Concertina.
For a moment,
they were unnoticed.
The explosions they created blending in with the mortars.
They broke through both sides of the j shaped hill just at its hook tossing
Satchel charges of explosives into the nearest bunkers.
Half of the bunkers on the artillery side,
unmanned as their defenders had helped with the fire.
Missions on the north compound were quickly taken by the Nva.
The rest of the perimeter swarmed.
We've creeping dashing,
set sappers.
Two bunkers were lost just down from third platoons.
Last position,
the sappers man of the bunkers.
After killing the occupants with Satchel charges and provided a beachhead on the
lines,
a stream of shadows poured into the compound between the bunkers,
the first cell of Nva that raced past the bunkers,
burned an entrance with a washing flame thrower.
It ignited the corner of a nearby 10 and two bright red answers from a host of
rifles fired from nearby bunkers.
There was no second wash.
It's trigger man and its mate lay dead beside low smolders from the torch lit
tent.
Another sapper team quipped quietly into the center of the compound and
encountered two almost identical bunkers and it tasted demolish the chapel
leaving the compound bleeding the command center bunker unscathed after the
chapel exploded in detonation that raised a blight,
bright flash and leveled the bunker in a smoking heap.
Another fierce mortar barrage shook the hill.
The North Vietnamese would attempt to take out more bunkers,
consolidate then retreat through the breaks in the they had made in the wire.
Speedy's gun teamed,
cringed in the stream bed on speaking,
wincing as the gun caught loose again,
it's explosion seem to be so close that one could reach up a hand and lose it to
a bullet.
Each man knew that if you were made an unworthy on,
untoward move revealing himself in any way,
the whole team would not last five minutes.
No where to go.
Nowhere to hide.
Yeah.
Well you know,
one of the,
uh,
have you ever had an aunt and Meyer entered Myers books?
I have not once an eagle.
I have not.
Um,
when we,
when the,
actually I think I have read once an eagle.
It's a great,
great book.
You know,
when,
uh,
when we sent the proofs around on,
on the fields,
the Prentice hall didn't quite know what to expect.
They,
you know,
the book had been rejected by 12 publishers.
Nobody wanted to see this side of it.
Uh,
and the,
the editor in chief apprentice,
all John Kirk had been on a naval aviator in the Korean War.
He was a Harvard graduate,
which I thought was kind of interesting cause when he asked me to come and talk
to him,
he asked me to meet him at the Harvard Club or you know,
good riches,
the Harvard Goofy,
you know,
but he said,
I think this can be the great novel,
you know,
he said,
the,
the great novels of different wards go against the grain of prevailing
orthodoxy.
Um,
and he made a deal with me.
He said,
you know,
I'll give you $5,000 had been working on this for four years.
They give you $5,000,
I'll print 5,000 copies.
Um,
but I will put your book on the cover of publishers weekly and I'll send you on
a major tour.
And I said,
you know,
done.
And he said,
oh,
actually the draft,
he had only had like a,
a five page epilogue when Goodrich.
And he said,
I actually like to see more of Goodrich coming back.
I said,
would you like the 28 page version,
the 35 page version number,
62 page version?
Totally look at that.
I gave him like a 30 page version,
but a typed page version back.
But then they started sending the book around,
um,
before publication date for advanced quotes and he got a torrent of them,
you know,
and the one,
one of the,
uh,
the advanced quotes that I treasured the most was from admire.
Um,
he had been a,
he also was a Harvard guy,
but he had been a marine in World War II,
uh,
had been on a,
either Guadalcanal or Iijima was wounded and wrote once an eagle,
which is a marvelous book.
I haven't read war and peace is like a thousand pages long,
but he,
uh,
he,
he took a one character,
well,
actually two characters,
but from before World War One all the way into Vietnam that we didn't call it
Vietnam in his book.
Um,
and you know,
one of them was a,
you know,
a Nebraska farm kid who was,
uh,
enlisted and you know,
and it got a battlefield commission,
World War One,
and the other was a,
you know,
west point guy who punched all the buttons.
Exactly right.
His name was Massengale.
Other one was Sam.
David.
Um,
but he wrote really good combat scenes and I,
I,
and I loved his book and he sent,
when he,
when he sent,
he sent this long advanced quote in his book and I,
yeah,
I just have all of them.
I'm like,
wow,
you know,
he said here at last is that the real story of those who were in Vietnam,
devoid of Histrionics,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
and um,
you know,
of,
but that,
you know,
when,
when you read passages like that,
I think of,
uh,
you know,
people like him,
um,
you know,
reacting to this gamble,
at,
at the time,
because there was nothing else like this at the till,
as was the first revisionist novel.
And I'll tell you,
when I went on my tour,
um,
I'd spent a year and a half on,
I was working on the house veteran's committee developing what I sort of,
uh,
a factual basis for discussion on the Vietnam War.
You know,
how long did people really serve?
How many were draftees,
how many were volunteers,
what,
what was the makeup of the casualties,
you know?
Uh,
and those who serve,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Just trying to lay the whole thing out year by year.
So I went out and the shows that I did,
that's what I wanted to talk about.
You know,
I would talk about this other stuff.
Um,
but there were,
you know,
I had some real moments and also by the way,
had been representing his so called war criminal pro bono from my first year in
law school,
who I represented for six years.
Uh,
he committed suicide halfway through.
I clear his name.
I,
I finally,
after six years,
but that wasn't very popular,
uh,
out there.
But,
uh,
I had,
I was on a radio show in Boston and I'm in the middle of the show.
This guy stopped.
He said,
I can't,
I can't tell,
hold us back any longer.
Don't you consider yourself to be a murderer?
Uh,
and I went,
no.
And actually what I said and not be in the intro and,
uh,
the American rifleman,
the shot or whatever,
I said,
no,
man is by nature of violent animal and society puts restrictions,
you know,
like [inaudible] me.
Give you ABC here,
you know,
society puts restrictions on how that violence is used.
And I don't consider myself to be a murder any more than,
you know,
a police officer.
Okay.
So,
and I had,
I was on a good morning,
Boston and a woman to produce.
You're so nice to me,
et cetera.
And right before I go to the store,
she said,
we used to hate you guys.
I said,
what?
She said,
no,
really.
I mean,
hate you.
Oh,
thank you for that.
Now going with the screaming wolf here,
you know,
um,
and it's interesting because,
uh,
I did a show in,
I think it was Cincinnati,
which was a TV show.
But speaking about the passage we just read,
right a little further in that passage,
there is a,
uh,
a sequence where there was a,
an enemy soldier who was in the trapped in the wire and he's all,
you know,
like kind of blown away.
And he starts yelling to Hawaii.
I surrender if you all eight you hallway and somebody yelled,
shut up and shot him.
And it's a woman who was interviewing me.
She says,
how can you put that in a book?
You know,
somebody who was trying to surrender who was shot.
And uh,
I said,
well look,
you know,
this is the reality of what was going on.
So she says,
I'm going to put that to a vote.
And she asked the viewers,
how many of you agree with them?
94% of them agreed with me.
I think she,
I think maybe we're starting to get somewhere here,
you know,
not,
not the lionizing shooting wounded soldiers,
but you know,
I mean reality is reality.
It is indeed.
Once you touch him,
then it's different,
you know,
uh,
and speaking of reality being reality and it's is a to to kind of point out some
of the reality that's in this book.
I got one more thing I want to read from it.
How'd you like to stay in on Okinawa,
sir?
That's right.
The major smiled.
Jesus Lieutenant,
I thought you would have jumped over the desk by now.
I'm on the level.
We just had a bill it open up over at special services recreation officer,
a lieutenant rotated early on emergency leave.
He had less than 90 days on his tour,
so he'll reassigned from the states.
I have the authority to fill the bill,
bill it from the transients who been in country already.
Your ideal combat time,
hospital time.
What'd you like it?
The major jived him greening.
Good duty.
Lots of free time.
Stick around Hodges.
We'll turn you into a hormone green.
Drunk.
A simple yes and the war would be over,
but so what?
Everything else and for the first time he confronted the truth.
Yes.
Major.
Thank you sir.
And the rest of his life would be anti climax.
There was nothing on the other side.
What does a man do when his wars over wondered Hodges except keep fighting it
all expectancies than lived and if not fulfilled?
Well at least confronted the bald red hills with their sandbag bunkers.
The banter and frolic of dirt covered grunts.
That fearful intensity of contact.
It was too deep inside him and he had not yet done enough to be free of it.
He suddenly felt superior to the major,
uh,
creature apart,
capable of absorbing,
combats horror without asking for quarter.
Okay.
Down South his men were on patrol or digging new perimeters or dying.
And he was nothing if he did not share that misery.
He stared deep into the majors face enjoying the one moment of nobility that is
months of terror had allowed
thanks major,
but I didn't call halfway around the world to referee basketball games,
the most powerful
and telling see,
or one of the most powerful until the scene seat,
tell me scenes in the novel is the way that I originally ended it,
which is,
which is with,
uh,
Michiko taking her son
to Camp Hansen
and she's on the one hand,
she's trying to exp,
you know,
to,
to build,
uh,
some positive feelings and him about the father he never knew and the price that
he was paying for being half American in,
in the Okinawan society.
And,
and she says,
what's this?
He says,
you know,
she takes him to Camp Hanson and you know,
cause he can,
she can see the marines air,
he could see the marines and air and he says it was,
was a good thing.
The am I like them,
then I'll be a warrior,
you know?
And,
and that's like,
whoa.
You know.
Um,
and then,
yeah,
when I was in the Senate,
it's very ironic.
We actually had a situation
on,
on Okinawa,
which was an exact replay,
um,
where I was able to help a family home marine,
who were deployed to Iraq and,
uh,
found out that his fiance was pregnant and they arranged
for them to be married on the phone and they had immigration issues and kid
issues and all this stuff.
And my counsel,
Trevor Mo was when it was handled,
when he was handling us,
I gave him a copy of fields of fire
cover.
Amazing course.
Speaking of sons,
I want to go here.
Back to,
uh,
I heard my country calling talking about as you were,
as you were heading off to Vietnam.
I would soon drive west heading for California where Barbara would rent a house
across the street from my granny and I would catch a flight to Vietnam.
My parents would clear their quarters at Andrews Air Force Base and that had
south to stay for awhile with my dad's longtime friend bud Caldwell as they
adjusted to the unknown's of retirement that awaited them in Florida.
Alpha had just begun.
Omega was not so happily done in less than 20 years.
Our lives had traveled to full circle.
I was now the one who is leaving.
My Dad was the one being left behind.
There was nothing left to say.
It was time to go.
We rose from the years Warren couches and began to say our final deliberate,
understated goodbyes.
We slowly made our way toward the front door of the farmhouse.
The radio in the dining room began playing Danny boy song by Johnny Cash.
I'm not sure that anyone other than God himself could have arranged the sweet
sorrow of that moment.
Johnny Cash was my favorite singer.
Danny boy,
emblematic of our long held Scots Irish heritage of military service is perhaps
the greatest song ever written about the painful anguish of a father watching
helplessly as his son marches off to war.
Oh Danny boy,
the pipes,
the pipes are calling from Glen to Glen and down the mountain side,
the summer's gone and all the roses falling.
Tis You two is you must go and I must bide become [inaudible] back when summer's
in the meadow or when the valley's hushed and white would snow.
Tis All be here in sunshine.
Orange Shadow.
Oh,
Danny boy.
Oh Danny boy,
I love you.
So
it was the first and only time I ever saw my father cry.
Yeah.
And then
30 odd years later you're sending your son into the Marine Corps.
The Iraq is escalating
cause this is what,
2003 I joined in early 2005 yeah,
it's full escalation mode at this point.
And
you're going through the same thing.
That's harder going through it.
I think,
um,
it's,
it's harder having a loved one gone done.
It is being gone emotionally.
I think.
Um,
yeah.
Uh,
okay.
My Dad was gone a lot.
Um,
I never expected that he would react that way,
you know.
Um,
and then when,
you know,
when Jim was gone,
it was,
uh,
it was hard for a lot of reasons,
partly because I was out there campaigning part of the time and this was a very
private thing to me.
I'm a father,
I refuse to talk about it other than in,
in general terms.
Um,
but uh,
he went,
he was able to call every now and then and send emails and that sort of thing.
And actually it made it a little harder,
you know,
cause you're getting a bit a piece here.
Yeah.
Um,
we had,
um,
just as a,
as an anecdote,
I've got to make like I think three phone calls from,
from Vietnam.
Um,
when you get back and,
and Wa,
uh,
you know,
on these Mars radio stations where you have three minutes,
you're standing there,
you got three minutes into it,
you got it.
You say something,
you go over and then they talk on the other end.
So I go,
hey mom,
I'm,
I'm here in Vietnam over and over where,
well,
I gotta go now.
But you know,
getting some of the bits and pieces of what's going on in,
in,
you know,
a Jim was very,
very well read and smart about that region.
So he was seeing things,
even as a lance corporal did.
A lot of people weren't.
That was tough.
And then,
you know,
truly waking up every morning and not knowing if your kids alive,
I mean that's the unknown's bother you.
I wouldn't unknown's and a partial knowns bother you more than actually being
there I think.
But yeah,
it's very hard,
but it's also our family boy,
you know.
And uh,
so,
um,
when he came back it was out to tell you a funny story.
They got extended on the surge,
you know,
one six got extended on.
Good job.
We got to stay longer.
Yeah.
And I think there was a,
there was a lot of fist fights going on at that boy.
And Jim's never back down from one,
anybody,
but on.
So I finally said to him,
uh,
an email.
All right,
when you get back,
anything you want,
he says,
um,
Yankees and red sox.
Fenway park May 19th.
Yeah.
I,
we have a great,
great friend and I got a lot of great friends and from South Boston Marine Corps
community up
there and I,
Tommy Lyons who was,
uh,
ran the veterans programs up there.
He got tickets.
And not only that,
but gentlemen,
one of his,
uh,
company mates who was from,
Boston,
they got off the plane at Logan and there was the state highway patrol waiting
forum that,
uh,
like a squad car,
whatever.
I don't know what it was,
but they had the sirens going and coming to come into Fenway and uh,
yeah,
I couldn't,
I couldn't have been any better.
A GM.
So how old were you when you were like thinking yourself?
All right.
Um,
I'm following in my dad's footsteps.
Earliest I could think there was,
uh,
two things.
I wanted to be a professional baseball player and a marine both at the same
time.
And when I was 13,
a good friend of mine,
uh,
we were warming up for a baseball game,
told me that could not happen.
And so it became kind of a binary choice.
But the Marine Corps is always at the front.
Uh,
my dad had a rope hanging in the back yard the entire time we were growing up.
I think it was one day he came home,
I don't know how old I was,
but I climbed it,
got back down and asked if I could be a marine.
And he's,
his reaction was that I needed to get some sort of organized athletics
immediately.
Need to wait 10 years.
When you were,
when you were born in Ramadi,
so you,
you had paid attention to what was going on in Ramadi and you guys knew you were
deploying there.
I missed three,
eight.
I had done an awesome job.
And they take,
I mean they've obviously taken a ton of casualties as had the whole one,
one AED in the two to eight before them and that,
and the,
the three eight actually overlap between the,
you know,
they were there.
Let's just like the first of the five Oh six,
they were there between when the two,
two,
eight left,
the three eight stayed the,
the first of five or six states.
Some of the other battalion stayed I think.
But so you guys both knew how bad Ramadi was when you were heading there.
Right.
And it's a,
that was go back to when we were announced that we were going there.
You mentioned last night there was some rumor that we were going to go on a
booze cruise,
there was going to be a reward for our battalion,
haven't done some seriously good work and Volusia and in Afghanistan.
And there is a,
uh,
a fairly,
I don't want to say it was dejection because that would sound wrong,
but it was kind of a whoa moment because we had heard what was happening two,
three,
eight and they were in a serious fight and all the unions that had been there
before that had been serious fights.
And I tried to get as much information as I could about the place that I was
going to be going.
And there wasn't much written quite yet.
There was a little bit about too for uh,
one of the first units marine units in there that was in print.
Um,
but in terms of press reports,
they were,
they were an eyeopener.
I believe there was an embed with three eight where there were detailing an
average day patrolling.
And these guys hop in walls and talking about the,
uh,
the average time to contact from leaving wherever you were was about five
minutes.
And it was,
it was an eyeopener in and I was a boot at the time.
Um,
and one of the,
one of the things that I would do would be,
would be going on Oh,
grish or live leak.
And I wanted to find some way to rationalize,
you know,
the TTPs of the enemy.
Could I s like could I see what they were setting up when they're videotaping
these complex attacks,
the IED strikes and there was really no way to do it.
Um,
you get a 32nd clip of a gun truck getting hit or a complex ambush.
And eventually one of my friends at the time,
a cliff Collins worth,
um,
he's passed,
you know,
laid into me one night about doing that.
It's like,
it's like you're not going to learn a damn thing.
You're just gonna get wrapped up in a ball,
knock it off.
And I took his advice and just play video games.
But it was,
uh,
it was,
it was interesting trying to get mentally prepared for it.
Um,
and I remember before we deployed,
I was in a hotel room with him and one of the things that stood out as you've
all these things going on as you know,
where a particular,
what's your first deployment in know family is trying to be there for you.
There's a lot of emotions flowing around and he said,
you know,
if you survive,
and that woke me up in a big way.
I had never thought that was going to be even a question.
And it was something that was relayed to me by not only my own father,
but by someone who had been through his own very serious combat experience.
Um,
and,
uh,
as I try to kind of rehash all this in my head,
I was,
I was brought back to a book that you reviewed on Vietnam a couple of podcasts
ago where this a new lieutenant was talking about getting ready to leave.
Um,
and you know how he was eating his meal the night before.
and there was absolutely no desire to be,
to have the meal,
to be involved with it.
His mind was somewhere else.
And the night before I deployed,
uh,
my cousins lived in Jacksonville.
Um,
my dad took us out to,
I believe it was sharp shooters and it's a burger joint,
favorite thing in the world.
Cheeseburger.
Um,
every year on my birthday,
my mom would make a special meal and I'd always ask for a cheeseburger and I got
a bacon double cheeseburger and basically just stared at it.
And all I could think about was where I was going to be in 48 hours and how the
world around me there was just going to keep going on.
Um,
and it was a very interesting period.
although he did make me famous a couple of months later cause the next morning
we're getting ready to go out and once he got an a Dale Wilson was there,
a triple amputee.
He actually walked up to our barracks room all night before we deployed.
Um,
you know,
walked up to the second or third deck.
Uh,
nobody could tell he was triple amputee,
hung out in the barracks with my dad,
uh,
and us for a bit.
And then in the next,
the uh,
the next morning getting ready to go on the bus and somebody,
I guess it was a whiskey or moonshine
you're on,
you're on the radio.
Whiskey
did a going away shots in the parking lot and there was a nice picture of it.
Cold months later interact.
My company first sergeant pulls me aside.
He's in New York Times article apparently about it.
Really?
Yeah.
Research better than we can read that on that
mentioned it wasn't anything crazy,
but he's like,
Oh really?
Web Drinking on the job.
It's like,
ah,
do we want to
talk to you by being able to communicate?
When I was campaigning for the Senate,
and this was like a couple of weeks before the election,
um,
Jim called me and he said three guys in his unit were killed.
And so
I'm in his car,
you know,
getting ready to go to a football game,
a big football game.
I'm down in the Norfolk area and I get that information,
you know,
and I'm like,
what do you do?
Yeah,
you put it in a box,
you buried the box,
you go do your thing and then you can come back and pull the box out.
But you know,
getting that and that's it,
you know,
like two or three minutes.
And then walking out and having to do like two or three hours saying hello to
people and not mentioning anything and whatever.
That,
you know,
that was really hard when,
when he was gone and when I was going through that,
let me ask you this kind of a critical question as a dad,
I'm going to come at you right now.
So if my son was getting ready to go on deployment,
I don't know if I'd say if you survive,
I'm not sure I said that he's,
that's something,
I mean I can see why you'd say it to,
you know,
as I'm sitting here trying to think about why would I tell my son that?
The reason I would tell if I was to tell my son that it'd be because I would
want him to stay sharp and on point the entire time and not take it for granted
and realize what's at stake.
So that might be,
I know,
I don't really remember the context in which I would have said that,
but uh,
you know,
I mean that's,
that's exactly how I took it.
Yeah,
it's stripped away.
There were like all aspects of the relationship except marine to marine.
And I've always been very cognizant of my dad's experience and reputation in the
Marine Corps.
And it was a very clear message that,
you know,
this is going to be different.
You're not special and you'd better pay attention.
So he might not remember saying it but it sounds like some good advice.
I'll keep that one in my back.
There were a lot of words going back and forth when he was getting ready to ship
out.
And,
and from,
from your perspective,
having grown up like with such a,
with such a focus on leadership and your family and the tradition in your family
and shown up as a lance corporal inside of a platoon and having more awareness
then the normal lance corporal would have.
Cause I'll tell you,
I mean if you're on picture of myself when I'm 19 years old,
if I was a lance corporal,
I would have been a normal lance corporal.
I would have been,
you know,
I wouldn't have had this sort of elevated look at things.
I mean even having read Your Dad's book over and over again,
and,
and just,
just that level of understanding.
Well,
how did that,
how did that set in your platoon?
How did that set with you?
Were you ever,
were you ever looking at your boss thinking or looking at your platoon commander
thinking,
Eh,
did he listen to you?
Did he talk to you?
Did he know who you were?
Did He,
was there anything like that?
They all knew?
Um,
I think the,
the best or the most amount of time I kept that off the skyline was two to three
days,
no matter which unit I was at.
Bootcamp,
I got pulled out and paraded around.
And it wasn't till I started asking questions,
this was before they actually kicked off the training or like,
Hey,
this is,
this is watch kid.
Um,
but,
uh,
I think it,
it put an extra,
extra demand,
particularly once I hit the fleet marine forces,
uh,
for humility because I could have,
you know,
all the informal,
um,
training if you like in the world.
And it was world class.
But at the same time,
I'm walking into an environment where I have not been there and done with these
guys have done and I need to listen.
Um,
and when the opportunity presents itself,
you know,
then the APP,
the practical application of what I had learned growing up would be there.
But until you earn your stripes,
you're nothing.
Um,
and uh,
I'll tell you to put an extra layer on him.
No,
no question about it,
particularly on the answers.
You know,
Jim has really,
really been smart and thoughtful about that part of the world.
So he had,
uh,
you know,
he had a lens on,
on what was going on that a lot of people at his level didn't have it.
Did you?
Okay,
here's a,
here's another question that I'll throw at you and we were talking about it a
little bit yesterday,
but,
um,
you know what I covered chesty puller and loophole or on this podcast number
one,
21,
number 21,
22,
if you haven't listened to them,
go listen to me.
If you don't know that story,
you should know what everyone should know it.
But you know,
Lou Lou polar got severely wounded as chesty puller son.
You know that,
that's another thing that would just,
I can't imagine though,
because you were friends with Lou polar.
Yes,
it was.
And you know,
you told me a story yesterday about you and him arguing about the draft
and
his,
his thoughts about that.
And I can't imagine that at some level you're thinking yourself,
well,
I know how I feel.
I know I'm patriotic.
I believe in service,
but this is my boy.
That's a hard choice.
Everyone has to make.
Um,
you know,
Lou Lou pulled her,
by the way,
I don't think we had a lot of debate,
but it never really got into an argument with him.
I,
I want to say that clearly because he was such a decent,
basically gentle guy,
you know,
but we certainly,
we certainly had our disagreements about policy and service and,
uh,
and wards in general.
I think by,
by the time he and I were hanging out,
uh,
he was a really,
really funny guy.
Um,
my,
you know,
for me,
Jim going into the military,
it's a part of a family tradition.
Um,
you accept the risk.
There's a,
an article I wrote for Parade magazine years ago about a father still tending
the grave of his son in Arlington.
I used to walk by it all the time.
It is one of the most beautiful stories about father and son and duty and
whatever.
The father was wounded in World War II and his son,
uh,
was one to three times and killed in Vietnam,
went back from Okinawa and was killed.
And um,
you know,
it's called the price of duty.
And actually mentioned Jim was really young when I wrote that piece.
But I mentioned,
you know,
he had already said he wanted to be a marine,
so you don't want to take away from someone what they believe that they,
they should do personally and for the country.
So I totally respect it.
And he just got to put your hands inside the bobsled,
you know,
uh,
and you also,
I,
I know we're,
we're,
we've been at it for a while,
but the,
the one other thing I wanted to ask you about is I talk about Hackworth a lot
and I know you interviewed him and spent,
you spent like a week with him.
Australia.
No,
actually,
yeah,
I was thinking I would get the Gig to go to Australia,
but we met in Hawaii,
which is not a bad,
not an accident.
Second place though,
I spent about a week with him,
um,
when he was,
you know,
I guess people who listened to you know,
know his backstory,
but when he was deciding to come home from Australia a after his exile for a
number of reasons,
uh,
in his book had not yet come out and,
um,
prayed magazine could not review books.
But I went and did a feature,
a long feature,
one of their longest pieces they'd done on,
on him and,
and you know,
read about and be beforehand,
talk to people,
knew him and then,
uh,
got to know him pretty well.
Kept up with him for years actually.
And he was a,
he was the kind of soldier that if you are going into a bad place,
you want to be with,
you know,
he was the real deal and end.
He had a hard time at the end for a number of reasons that I pointed out in,
in,
in the article.
Um,
I phrased it in a certain way and my article,
you know,
um,
uh,
I think it was a quote,
um,
one of the people that serve with him that,
you know,
he,
the army disappointed him and he just decided to declare war on that.
But he was a soldier.
And um,
yeah,
I,
I thought a lot of of him,
that part of his life.
Well,
it's some of the stuff you told me and I read that article and Jim,
thanks for,
for that to me.
And I had actually read it before,
but I hadn't made the connection.
You know,
I didn't look at the author's name.
I apologize.
I just folded up,
read the article.
I didn't make that connection,
but I should have,
um,
you know,
obviously thanks to both of you for coming on and,
and,
and thanks for your service.
And we'll put the links to buy these books.
And there's a new version coming out of fields of fire.
There was an anniversary,
a 40th anniversary edition that they've put out already in the kindle form.
And that will be out by December in,
uh,
in the paperback.
It's no different other than nerves.
I was short essay in the front that I wrote,
you know,
dance to cover up a little bit.
Glad to know it's still in print in a while.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's,
it's in print and there's,
there's lots of,
um,
I'll just say there's lots of books and movies and series and TV shows that,
I don't know how to say this,
but they can,
they can,
they reflect,
certainly reflect some of the characters and some of the goings on inside the
book.
So I'd love to,
I'd love to see fields become a,
probably a TV series.
I wrote a proposal a year ago on it and we,
you know,
Hollywood's funny,
it's a,
when I was working out there a lot,
I think they were registering 40 close to 40,000 screenplays a year of the
writer's guild and we were making 260 movies.
So you know,
you get to that final cut off,
it's a pretty competitive,
but uh,
would like to see that.
It's been a pleasure being with you.
It's been a great conversation.
Thanks for,
thanks for coming on.
And I would maybe propose this and I know it's a long trip,
so maybe next time I'll do the trip.
But we've done this once before.
We did it with a novel Musashi,
which is told people where you're going to do it.
And then once everyone had the chance to read it,
we came back,
I came back on and I had a friend of mine,
Tim Ferriss,
who was an Asian studies major at Princeton and had lived in Japan and studied
judo and we went through the book and kind of Parse it apart.
But,
uh,
if you'd ever like to do that,
let me know and thank you.
Come back on and,
um,
we'll go through it and pull,
you know,
I,
I didn't,
you know,
I like talking about leadership.
The leadership lessons inside fields of fire are phenomenal.
Just the pattern recognition of knowing what kind of people you're dealing with.
And you can learn a lot of that just from the book.
But I'd love to hear about how you got to some of those characters.
One of my one real obvious character is Austin,
uh,
Sergeant Austin,
who's like the,
by the book marine.
That's,
hey,
it's my way or the highway and,
and just the way,
you know,
just the way that Hodges kinda handles them.
And,
and there's a certain,
there's a conversation they're having and you can see Hodges is pushing,
not pushing back up against them a little bit.
And then he decides,
no,
you don't.
I'm not gonna Pat push back any further,
cause I'm going to create a relationship with this guy and we'll get them along
the way.
But those little subtleties that you put in this book are,
are phenomenal leadership lessons.
One small point on that,
cause I probably should have mentioned it earlier in terms of one of the
motivations and writing and is there,
there was so much out there,
demeaning things that happened in Vietnam without a comprehensive understanding,
not only of Vietnam,
but of warfare in general,
that
I felt like it was important to,
to create characters that could give context to how some of these things happen.
You know?
Um,
that's what Sergeant Austin,
how do you know the,
the,
the numbers,
um,
you know,
when I was in,
in,
in law school and writing us about,
everybody was getting fragged,
you know,
and I remember I had a really good friend who was a World War II veteran who was
needling me one day saying,
tell me about fragging.
I said,
screw you.
I was raised on stories of a bad lieutenant in World War II,
having 10 seconds once the ramp dropped on the landing craft for somebody who
was going to get him out of the way.
And he said,
well,
I shot a lieutenant.
I don't know if he was true or not,
but you know,
there,
there are leadership lessons in it,
in the book and are also in Austin is one of them.
I mean,
how do you,
how do you create positive environments?
If you look at where these people had been at the time that he was coming in and
doing the,
you know,
the pre Vietnam junk on the bunk,
uh,
which was probably essential to developing an attitude of discipline when you
didn't have this stuff.
But,
um,
you know,
somebody,
you got 1.3,
3.7 million people over the 500,000 people in Vietnam at the time.
A lot of them from pretty rough backgrounds and,
uh,
you know,
there,
there are ways to motivate them,
you know,
in,
in the ways when things go the other way.
There's ways to get yourself fragged
well,
that doesn't happen often,
but it was not,
it,
it did happen,
you know,
uh,
at times and it's probably always happened.
It has and in some form or another.
That's why it's important to be a good leadership,
be a good leader,
especially when the people that you're leading have weapons.
So,
uh,
well again,
and that's one of the many multitude of,
of lessons that are in the book.
And again,
we'll put them on the website so everyone can get them and you can educate
yourself.
Uh,
Jim,
you got any,
any final thoughts?
Anything else to say?
Thanks for having us.
She's incredible.
Just listening to you to talk back and forth.
It's amazing.
Well,
it's been a real pleasure.
Well thanks for coming on.
Obviously it's,
it's an honor to have you on and I think anyone that's going to listen to this
or anyone that does listen to this and you're going to hear from a lot of people
that do listen to this,
um,
they keep their,
their minds open,
keep their hearts humble.
As you both have talked about today,
do you guys have set an incredible example for people to follow?
And thanks for coming on.
It's been an honor to talk to you and we appreciate most of all your service to
the country and yours gangs.
And at this time our guests have departed the studio.
Awesome.
To have them on an honor to sit and talk with such men and,
and it's,
it's just an honor to be able to do that again.
Incredible story.
Incredible books and get them the books will be on the website on Jocko,
podcast.com under books,
books from episode from episodes is what the technical name is.
Cool.
Yeah.
Um,
I think everyone can learn from those books
if you read them.
Speaking of learning,
speaking of teaching and whatnot,
Echo Charles,
maybe you could teach us how to,
you know,
get after it a little bit harder.
Sure.
First of all,
we'll shift gears to do you do to obviously seems obvious.
Seems obvious.
Yeah.
And I,
I think you're in the same boat where
you default to Jujitsu as like a solution or a way to look at things even
earlier today we're talking about true.
It is.
Yeah.
It is a default way to,
well,
I've talked about it before.
The fact that it's a thread that ties a lot of things together.
Yeah.
That's comparable to a lot of things.
It's a struggle.
Life is a struggle.
Businesses a struggle.
Combat is a struggle.
All these things are a struggle and you have to learn to deal with them and they
all have threads in them that are the same.
So yes,
I do refer to Jujitsu from time to time.
If you don't like that,
go start your own podcast and don't talk about Jujitsu.
Dang Bro.
Wait,
are you saying to me if I don't like that,
but when you think you're talking to,
okay,
I'm just making sure I remember.
Actually I'm remembering it right now that you referred to to as the solution to
something humility.
That's what it is.
Well that if you want to work on humility used you do through that is the
answer.
That'll help you anyway.
While you do that,
you're going to need a geek because we're going to do both Gi and Nogi.
So when you get your Geek,
no question,
go to origin main.com to get your geek.
That's where you get 100% yeah,
no doubt,
no doubt.
And you can get rash guards there for going to train.
No,
you don't have to use a g in Jujitsu.
You can.
I recommend that you do and if you're wondering if you do do should do to GI or
no Gi do both.
Yeah.
That's just,
that's just the way to go.
They're both,
we'll help each other and they're both useful and,
but you can get rash guards if you're going to do Jujitsu with rash guard,
which is good thing to do because it doesn't get all caught up in your
opponent's toes.
Yes.
There's not too many things in life.
When you're worried about your opponent's toes.
In Jujitsu you are a little bit worried about your opponent's toes and you're on
us by the way.
Yeah,
and you can use the rash guards for other activities such as surfing,
cycling,
you don't cycle.
I know.
I hear good things.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well I guess you can wear them for a cycling as well and,
and spats,
don't forget about spats spats,
which is essentially compression pants were caution.
They're essentially a rash guard for your legs,
for your low,
your other 50% of your buddy.
Oh,
as Dean Lester would say,
let's check.
Plus there you got tee shirts,
they got close and we're making more clothes at origin.
We are making more clothes at origin.
Yeah,
yeah.
Standby.
Yup.
I called Pete the other day and you didn't get yours yet.
No.
You jeans and that was really the topic.
Critical about that one.
So yeah,
we're going to make an all close.
Keep just keep paying attention to that and we'll get them out.
Um,
supplements.
We've got some good supplements,
things that will help you in all aspects of getting after it.
For instance,
help your joints with joint warfare.
Help your joints with Krill oil.
Help your cognitive and physical capacity.
Yes,
with discipline.
And there's actually so discipline,
we just made a new form of discipline.
So there's the discipline powder drink.
Cool.
Here's the problem with the discipline powder drink.
I'm getting ready to go into a meeting and I'm going to be in there for two
hours and I want to get like a little bit of a cognitive bump.
You know what I'm saying?
A little bit of a and a little,
a little bump.
And I don't maybe want to drink,
uh,
a thousand or drink 500 milliliters of water or whatever,
a bottle of water and only drink a bottle of water because I'm then,
you know,
biologically what's going to occur in 45 minutes.
If I pounded a bunch of water,
I'm gonna have to quit,
stop and use the head.
Yeah.
Quit.
But I'm gonna have to stop for a moment can use,
which I don't like.
So made a want,
you know,
some pills,
uh,
a capsule actually a capsule.
So boom,
it's got the,
it's got a little caffeine and to get it,
it's got some nootropics in it gets you a little bit of a,
does it get,
does it have more caffeine than the regular?
No.
Okay.
Well on the go,
yeah.
It's discipline on the go.
Yeah.
Discipline on the go.
Okay,
interesting.
Yeah,
I have mine took some good,
oh,
you got yours.
Oh yeah.
Oh I don't,
I mean obviously I don't go now obviously,
but I don't go into many.
Ap took someone if he took something and he said like a text to me and Pete and
Brian,
he was like,
oh,
okay.
So that I don't feel fired up one a,
well JP feels fired up anyway,
so I'll just like enhance,
you can tell GP going on stage,
everything's clicking for him.
You know,
he's fired up 100%.
Um,
Bob mock the mock train.
Yep.
Big Time.
Stay on it.
It's kind of hard to get the problem with the milk train is you just add ends up
just being sort of kind of a dessert.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
And it's interesting because you know the,
the idea that protein powder is,
it's either it tastes good or it's good quality.
That's it.
That's a dichotomy that used to exist,
exist.
The,
the,
the gap in that dichotomy could not be crossed,
could not be brought together.
It has been brought together.
Been both,
again,
I was talking to my friend Terry,
Aka big sexy last night.
He's got them all trained.
No,
that's the thing.
I might as well have just made a commercial for it because you know how you
start talking about it,
then you start taking it and you get yourself kind of fired up about it.
You know,
that's what I was doing anyway.
He was like,
hey man,
I got it.
It's good.
It gets on the train.
Hopefully a mint chocolate chip.
My personal favorite peanut butter chocolate,
Dave Burke's personal favorite.
Good deal too.
Vanilla gorilla.
Technically named,
not directly for Leif Babin and when certainly associated with wave back.
And he said the other day that he mixed it up and he was like,
Whoa,
the,
he's at gay,
I've Nyla and he was pumped on the vanilla gorilla.
And then there's the darkness.
Yup.
Which is just pure chocolate.
Yes.
And your chocolate in my household,
the darkness is ascending to Oh really?
Mint chip chocolate levels.
Cause it has like a case.
Who's who's,
Oh,
it's right here.
Yeah.
Yup.
Interesting.
I still add peanut butter in it by the way.
I should,
I should mention that.
That I could understand.
Yeah.
But,
um,
also,
you know,
we,
we also just came out with warrior kid milk.
We've got strawberry and chocolate right now.
They have a little bit less protein.
I mean cause if your kids eight years old,
he who should hopefully get and put a protein from natural food sources.
The problem is sometimes they don't get enough and got,
got some protein in there.
We've got vitamins in there,
got some probiotics in there.
Cause we know Timmy,
when he hears about the probiotics,
he gets fired up and this is the amazing thing.
They are delicious.
They are just freaking delicious.
And so in my house,
the strawberry kids milk is just getting crazy.
I as soon as I tasted the strawberry kids milk,
I sent Brian a text and said make adult warrior kid mark immediately now.
So he's got that comment.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Adult strawberry
and I called it strawberry quick the other day.
Your brain will cause it tastes that good.
It's,
it's,
it literally tastes like strawberry quick.
Yeah.
The chocolates damn good too.
But anyways,
that's the warrior kid.
This is the only drink because the only thing that you got with your kids that
you want your kids to have it as bad as they want to have it.
There's no other thing in the world.
It's like that.
Yeah.
This is it.
Maybe the warrior kid books.
Yeah.
That's possible.
I was drinking mountain dew the other day.
Hell,
straight up.
What is up with you?
They just have it.
Bear with me.
Why are you doing problems?
Have nonetheless I was,
and I came to kind of this realization fired.
I'm telling you.
Okay,
so quiet.
So bear with me.
You know,
I'm not pounding mountain news every day.
I'm not saying that,
but as I drink,
this is a sleep.
As I drink this mountain.
Do you know how you kind of like reflect on things and so I'm like,
okay,
what am I drinking?
He's good.
I like my,
I've always liked mountain dew since literally the first time I tasted when I
was a kid.
And so I'm like drinking it and I'm like,
you know what,
I'm drinking right now.
It's,
it's liquid candy is what I'm drinking.
Literally like,
you know,
you don't like a jolly rancher or one of these,
that kind of candy.
They make lollipops and stuff,
Consider this exact flavor,
this exact flavor,
not more sweet,
not less sweet.
This exact mountain dew flavor as a lollipop or jolly rancher.
It would fit.
It would be like,
yeah,
and I'm just drinking the liquid form of it.
Literally.
That's what I'm thinking is you finish the camp.
Well it was one of those small cans.
Did you finish it?
Yeah,
I was eating Sushi.
You know how it is like it's the whole deal nonetheless.
That's what it is.
But there's no reason for this anymore because now we have milk.
Yeah.
And you can kind of consider the difference,
right.
Where the,
you know,
your kid,
if they're like how I was and you see the mountain dew as a kid,
you're like,
I don't want that.
But the parents are like,
no,
we don't drink.
Why don't you drink Jocko white tea instead?
Bring a can with you.
Well it's,
you know,
I have a bunch of game.
It's a long story,
you know.
Then we're working very hard on the whole situation,
but nonetheless it happened and you know we're going to move on,
but if you're a kid,
you want them mountain dew.
I noticed now it's a mountain dew is right up there with cotton.
An important,
that's how you say it.
Satisfied a key nonetheless.
If this will you compare the scenarios kid wants them out to do.
It's like,
yeah,
of course you want them on the tastes good,
but the it's like,
no,
we don't drink mountain dew.
That's crap.
That's liquid candy.
Wouldn't you know that?
We're not doing that.
It's not healthy for us.
But the kid wants to milk boom parent.
Yes.
Every,
every time parents per say,
Hey,
do you want some more milk?
Yeah.
Yes,
I do actually check.
Cool.
Good.
So that's,
that's origin main.com for all that stuff.
A lot of good stuff on there.
Also,
we have a store as a store called Jocko store.
Anyway there you can get also get rash guards,
some cool shirts if you want to represent discipline equals freedom.
Few designs on that one.
There's some designs on there on that store in general.
So yeah,
men check them out.
If you want to get something,
get something.
Truckers hats.
My wife said something about Jocko store and then my youngest daughter said,
you have a store?
And I said,
yeah.
And she says,
where is it
on the Internet,
man?
Virtual Jocko store.
It's called Jocko store.
Tell them,
let your friend know.
But yeah,
some good stuff.
Some hoodies on there as well.
Hats,
as Jacqui said,
trucker and flex fit.
But yeah,
go on there and you know,
if you want something,
if you'd like something,
get something good way to stay on the path and represent at the same time.
Boom.
Do you rep when you're,
does it help you stay on the path?
I think so,
yes.
There's,
there's quite a few people that feel when they put on the uniform,
right.
June the game.
You know what's a classic art typical part of the hero's journey is they're
getting their gear on Sudi.
No,
no.
They're suiting up.
That's part of the deal.
And watch a movie.
What do they show that?
Whether it's a soldier getting his boots on lock and load his weapon.
You know,
when the movies,
when they open up like the war chest.
Well yeah,
cause I can like in Mike in the dragons to opens up the war chest,
right in commando,
commando gearing up gets onto the shore.
The final battle scene,
right.
You get on the shore.
Oh yeah.
It was like a whole montage boots,
a bulletproof vest.
Uh,
you know,
I dunno if it was bulletproof.
I Dunno.
It doesn't matter.
He's zipping it up.
I think that vest is more just,
you know,
just dope.
Just
grenades on it.
Just Hollywood a hundred percent.
They paint the face with the thing.
Well,
you know,
the charcoal that they paint their face with all it's cotton candy paint.
Yeah.
Breath.
I'm telling you it's suiting up because of that.
Um,
yeah,
you can,
you can get suited up and then you feel like you're getting in the zone for
whatever it is you're about to go do because you got that shirt that says
whatever.
Well,
big time.
Yeah.
When you get a new rash guard,
you're that much more compelled to go train.
If you,
this is a thing that starts when you're like six years old and you get a new
pair of shoes and it just lasts your whole life.
Oh yeah.
Well yeah.
Actually the shoes.
That's a good example because remember when you're a kid,
I dunno,
you might be different,
but I think most of us when we're a kid,
you know when you got the new shoes,
you want to go to school.
I want to see your thinking functionality,
which I did by the way.
But you get the new shoes that knew chuck Taylors.
Mm.
The half red half green ones.
Do you read those ones?
Anyway,
we had those.
And so you buy them or you get on whatever from parents and you're like,
can't we just wear these to school?
Oh.
And like everyone's going to see all this stuff.
So compared to if you don't have new shoes,
do you really want to go to school?
Sure.
Maybe,
maybe not.
But with the chuck Taylor,
the new shoes you will want to go.
That's how,
same thing with the gym.
The same thing with anywhere.
If you've got some new clothing to represent with big time check do you were
dry.
Dry Fit is,
I think it's what it's called.
You wear a dry fit,
right?
W in what?
Like a shirt way.
It's called dry fit for like working out.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's like we don't have any of that.
We need to,
and I know that's what I was doing.
I just thought of that right now.
Just thought of that.
Here's the thing,
I knew that before because you,
I think you and some people
I'm working on,
we're working on it.
We're working on it at origin that we can make dry fit.
Not a compression like loose fit,
right?
Yeah.
Who's fit loose?
Fit,
quick.
Dry.
That's what we're making.
Yeah.
I gave you a pretty dope red one at the muster and I was like,
I don't wear a dry fit at all.
I put it on and I was like,
Dang.
I,
I like it.
It's good.
It's boom.
It's kind of on my radar now.
Yeah.
Well,
I think you measure most shirts by their sleeves size.
It's that must add some small sleeves and you were stoked.
That's classified anyway.
Also stay on the path,
keep stay on the path,
keep yourself on the path by subscribing to this podcast.
I know it seems obvious,
but sometimes when people are new they're like,
oh yeah,
cool podcasts in fact or a year in that trial period.
Cause there there are certain podcasts that I'll be like,
hey,
I hear good things,
I'm gonna go listen to it.
And I only listened to it like at the gym or something like this or on under
certain circumstances and I'll forget,
you know,
like I won't listen to it at other times.
So we'll come back to the gym or something like that and go,
Oh let me find that podcast.
And you got to kind of do the search or whatever you just subscribed.
So I can see that scenario being the case.
You see what I'm saying?
For people,
cause you know,
how will we say?
Of course they gonna subscribe seems obvious.
It's obvious enough to tell people subscribe.
They're either going to subscribe if they like it or not,
but sometimes you do forget there are circumstances what I'm saying.
So here's a reminder.
Subscribe.
You're subscribing to this podcast also subscribed to the warrior kid podcast.
We have some more warrior kid podcast episodes coming.
I apologize that they're taking long.
It is my fault for not being more squared away,
prioritizing better and working harder,
but I have some almost ready for the release.
Cool.
Uh,
also while you're looking at warrior kid stuff,
you can check out Irish oaks ranch.com and get some,
some war.
Your kids soap from American made soap from a 13 year old kid that is raising
goats,
getting the milk from the goats and turning it into soap.
Good soap to buy on a farm here in California.
A lot of people don't know that California is massive agriculture and farming,
so you can support that with a little warrior kid soap.
All snow.
Forget about the youtube while you're subscribing.
You can subscribe to the Youtube Channel Jocko podcast where you can watch these
podcasts on there.
If you want to see us.
If you want to see Jim Webb and James Webb,
you want to see what their reactions are and see what they look like.
You can subscribe or you can go to youtube and check it out.
You can also see echoes enhanced videos,
which he is quite proud of.
I'm proud that you use the word legit and Willie are legit.
I will give you a credit when credit is due and they,
they enhance the message functionally.
Sure.
Like being able to read the words.
That's functional usage,
so it's not just,
it's not just affects for the sake of effects,
which I probably wouldn't call legit.
You know,
you do throw some of that stuff.
It,
some walls are exploding.
Rehab might be a little bit beyond,
but sometimes he goes a little too far.
Let 'em know.
Let 'em know if his videos are a little bit much ship.
He learns.
It's like the guy that learns something and they learned the cow bell.
They get a new cow bell for the drum set and they put it in through the whole
album.
It was just cow bell.
What's the cowbell?
It's like a,
it's a cow bell.
I mean and but people use it in music occasionally.
It should be used sparingly.
Actual codes.
The cowbell thing or like more like a bone.
I can't really do the noise.
Sure.
But they're there because in dresser she drums actually all instruments really?
They have like names for,
you know like high hat?
Yeah.
There's the name of the drug.
I know,
but see what I'm saying though,
that's like a name for a job.
Like if you'd never seen a drum or never heard of a joint sentences,
high hat,
they'd be like,
I know what high means and I know what hat means.
High had is the name for you see what I'm saying?
I thought that was the same deal for cow bell.
No,
no,
no.
It's actual,
they make,
I mean I don't know what the cow bells look like in 1850 but this has definitely
been cleaned up and modified so that it's a cow bell.
Laura thing,
but it's for your,
you don't,
you don't go to the farm store to buy a cow bell for your drum set.
Okay.
Go to the music store and he say,
I need a cow bell.
I understand.
And they say,
and then you start using it in every song and you think everyone wants to just
hear that cow bell.
Yeah.
Cause he's like,
yeah.
And there's a whole skit on Saturday night live about the cow bell.
Okay.
I was just going to have one of the patches that guys had NTU bruiser that
eventually got banned.
One of the patches was more cowbell based on the Saturday night live skit.
Gotcha.
Okay.
And I always did actually wonder about that more cowbell that now you know,
you never know what you're gonna learn.
Also psychological warfare,
that's an album with tracks where you can stay on the path and we're making
another one in,
just coming out soon.
And that's it on that.
Good.
Also if you want to vary up your workout,
get more workout gear,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko also they got some good immunity stuff
that I actually took.
It reminded me cause I,
I just took some felt the cold coming on.
Shroom tech commune.
It's a good one.
You liked that one very much like one.
Never let me know before he traveled.
Take that.
Nonetheless,
a lot of cool stuff on there and information.
That's another one that like you can get caught up in a bad way but it's a good
resource when you want to vary up your workouts and do some new workouts,
kettlebells,
even that,
that club workout,
which I would highly recommend looking into what to do.
Don't just speak to that thing up and start getting nuts.
Might get you my champion on you also got Jocko white tea,
which tastes delicious and it's good for you.
I say again,
tastes delicious and good for you.
That seems to be the theme.
Yeah.
If we're going to put something in our body,
we want it to taste good.
Yes,
and we want it to be good for us.
Jocko white tea and there's no doubt that it's good for you because there's,
it's the only product,
the only product that I've ever heard of where an 8,000 pound dead lift is
guaranteed.
100% never failed me too.
It's so good.
You some of that get your dead lift up.
Also,
we've got some books.
Uh,
first of all the books we read today and,
and James Webb's,
James Webb has 10 books that he's written.
Uh,
the two that we covered today will both be on the website,
fields of fire.
And then I heard my country calling.
These are the two books I rented a,
he also mentioned a book called the Nightingale Song,
which is a great book and we'll put that one on as well.
Did you hear me?
No.
Nightingale's song night.
Gale Song.
Yep.
Great Book.
It's about the class that the naval academy guys that graduated with Jim Webb
and what they did,
they all had a huge impact on the navy and on the country.
And it's,
well the,
this particular group that he talks about,
so we'll put that book on there as well cause it's a great book and perhaps I'll
cover it at some point.
Obviously for booked.
We also have way of the warrior kid and Mark's mission.
If you know kids,
get them these books and you know,
get them on the right path of the,
of going in the right direction of doing the right things.
It's just going to be,
it's going to help kids out there.
The feedback that I've gotten from around the world and yes,
I've gotten feedback from around the world by around the world.
I mean Australia,
New Zealand,
I've gotten a whole package of letters from a classroom in New Zealand who have
kids that are on the path.
So if you read a book,
imagine you read a book and you're seven years old,
nine years old,
and you decided that the book was good enough that you were going to try and
find the author who lives on the other side of the world and write him a note
and say thanks,
because I'm on the path now.
That's the book right there where the warrior king and Mark's mission also
discipline equals freedom field manual.
This,
you know what?
This is Christmas time.
You get to Christmas,
this book is a gift.
It's a gift for people that you know that you want to help.
If you have an enemy,
don't give it to him because then your enemy's going to get on the path.
Probably come back and whatever,
18 months and there'll be jacked and there'll be focused and they'll crush you
or,
yes,
you're right.
Or they could if they,
well I guess if they're,
it depends on their level of,
of malevolence their soul because if they have a little bit of good in there,
you know if they're going to do,
they're going to read that little part about laughter wins and they're going to
see that the light is going to overcome the darkness and maybe they'll come back
to you in 18 months and like,
hey,
I got you something.
Boom.
Now we're not enemies anymore.
We're moving in the right direction.
By the way,
do you want to train by the way,
do you want to Jackson steal by the way,
do you want to go out and eat some steak cause I'm down.
So that might actually be the movie there.
That could be the move.
Nicely done.
I like the way you think that audio book is not on audible.
It is on iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
other MP3 platforms.
Extreme ownership.
First Book I wrote with my brother Leif Babin.
That's I'm
taking the principles that we used in combat and then applying them to business
and life and then we followed that up with another book called the dichotomy of
leadership,
another New York Times bestseller,
which is super cool and all that,
but whatever.
Let's face it.
What we wanted to do was write a book that actually expanded and made people
better leaders.
Feedback we're getting on that one is that's what it's helping people do.
The little,
the little nuances of extreme ownership that are,
that are harder to handle and harder to master.
This book will help you do it.
That the dichotomy of leadership available everywhere.
Appreciate everyone getting that.
Of course now we have Mikey and the dragons.
It is coming out
November 15th I'm trying to get as many printers as I can right now because you
all ordered a lot of them,
so thank you.
And it's about a little kid who's scared of everything and he finds a book,
and in the book the king is dead in this village and this kingdom,
and there's a prince that's going to have to stand up and fight.
So that's what he,
that's what he does to the prince has to stand up and fight.
But he's scared because he's only seven.
So
that's that little little excerpt from it did a little expert excerpt.
I'd do a little extra.
The king.
I had always been so strong and brave and protected the kingdom from the Dragon
Cave.
The Dragon Cave was just over the hill and filled with scary creatures that were
ready to kill horrible dragons of every single type who thought.
People in the kingdom were especially ripe,
that people thought the dragons had breath of fire and that the dragon stood 20
feet tall or higher.
They fought.
The dragons had soared stopping scales and powerful long razor sharp tails.
But the brave king never let the beast around.
He stood up and fought and held his ground.
And as long as the king had been the king,
none of the dragons could do a thing.
Yes.
The king always kept the dragons at bay by going out bravely into the fray.
It seemed without fear that king would go fight.
He'd beat the dragons and come home at night.
But now that the king had died and was gone,
there was only one person to fight and carry on.
But that person wasn't big,
are mightier strong.
In fact,
he hadn't been alive that long.
Now the person who had dragons to chase was just a little boy with a smiling
face.
Yes.
The person that now must stand up and be bold was just the little prince who was
only seven years old.
So.
So there you go.
Of course the villagers are worried if this little kid is going to be able to do
it and well get the book.
You find out what happens when he goes up to face the dragons.
And by the way,
you guys put this book to number 17 on Amazon of all books.
Prerelease that's crazy.
So you guys called me out and I'm printing as fast as I can and the good news is
I'm printing more of these first additions,
so the first additions is going to continue.
I'm going to print as many as I can and get it out and get it to everyone,
hopefully by Christmas.
Appreciate it for the support against,
against the big boys.
Yeah.
Speaking of big boys,
and you remember how you used to talk trash about the publishing company
charter?
Be All conservative and look at,
you know,
yeah.
I,
I was uh,
I was conservative and I was too conservative.
I didn't realize how much people were going to get after it.
And I got texts from my buddies that are saying,
I just ordered 10 copies.
I just ordered 14 copies.
I just ordered 19 copies for every kid in my extended family.
And I'm like,
that's awesome.
I will get them printed as fast as I needed to.
I pulled out all stops and I'm making it an advocate.
You know what?
It's my fault.
I should have.
I should have ordered more of those exact things that you said about yourself
were the exact same things you were saying about the publishing company.
Yeah.
I didn't know how people were going to get after it.
You just said that about the publisher.
They don't understand.
Maybe I if apparently I didn't understand.
I should have taken my own advice now.
We do.
Now we know.
There you go.
The books are being printed as fast as I can print them.
What I like about you so apologize for that.
It's my fault.
I should have taken my own advice and well now I'm getting after it this.
Yes you are.
We'll get 'em out there.
Printing a ton more.
Also Echelon Front leadership consultancy.
We solve problems through leadership.
That's what we do at the echelon front team.
Me,
Leif,
Babin,
JP to Nell,
Dave Burke,
Flynn Cochran,
Mike Cirelli and Mike [inaudible].
So if you need help in your organization,
call us,
call us now because we are booked up.
So if you are thinking about doing this in a future call now on front.com go get
on there and we'll hook up.
Also muster 2019 we've got Chicago and Denver dates aren't completely locked
yet,
but check extreme ownership.com for the information and to end to find
out when it is live and when you can book and make your reservations.
All the monsters have sold out and this one,
these will too.
So get on it early enough,
Overwatch as well.
We're connecting SPEC OPS and combat aviators to companies that need leaders.
So the military produces trains and tests in combat environment leadership and
we're taking those leaders,
those experienced leaders and bring them into the civilian sector ETF,
overwatch.com if you want to get on in the game on either side,
so whether you're a Spec ops or your combat aviation and you're looking for what
your next mission is going to be or you're a company that's looking for
experienced,
trained leaders to come and help you out.
Folks that understand the mentality of extreme ownership and what we do at
echelon front.
Go to e f over watched.com and if you want to keep discussing these things with
us,
we are available on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram and on dad fee.
She Book Echo is at Echocharles and I am at Jocko Willink and thanks once again
to James and Jim Webb for their service and for joining us on the podcast to
share their lessons learned.
It was an honor to be able to sit and talk with them and thanks to everyone else
that has served or is serving in the military around the world out there holding
the line and also thanks to police and law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
EMT,
correctional officer's border patrol,
all the first responders,
everyone that is out there doing what you do for us on the home front.
Thank you for what you do every day
and to everyone else that is listening.
Thanks for listening.
Thanks for supporting.
Thanks for spreading the word.
It is much appreciated.
And in the book fields of fire,
one of the main characters,
Hodges,
in part of the book,
he quotes an old hymn and old hymn that he's thinking about in his head.
And that old hymn says,
time like an ever rolling stream bears all its sons away.
They fly,
forgotten as a dream dies at the opening day.
So there you go.
A little reminder.
Okay.
A little reminder to all of us that time is fleeting.
Okay?
Time is short and we only get so much,
so don't wait around.
Okay?
Don't put it off.
Instead,
get up
and yes,
get after it.
Until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.